monsieur le Président cher Laurent
mesdames et messieurs en vos grades et
titres de président vice-président
vice-présidente qu'au présidente
d'abord merci merci d'être venu au Sénat
parce que c'était pas forcément
même pour les sénateurs
un jour un jour favori mais quand nous
fixons nos programmes nous ne pouvons
pas savoir quels seront l'ampleur des
mouvements des mouvements sociaux et
voilà mais enfin certains sont là et je
pense que les communs à la fois la
commission de la culture mais la
commission des affaires européennes sont
bien présents et c'est important
la liberté de la presse est un pilier de
la démocratie et il importe de la
préserver en Europe et dans notre pays
en ces temps où la démocratie est remise
en cause dans ces dans ces fondements à
nos frontières même et d'entendre pays
d'entendre pays du monde et à l'heure où
la désinformation se répand partout sur
les réseaux sociaux nous étions hier
dans une réunion à Matignon avec la
première ministre et l'un des piliers
sur eux en fait sur le comité
de cohésion entre France et Ukraine donc
avec à la fois les militaires mais aussi
les politiques et le pilier de la
désinformation et a été évoquée de façon
de façon très importante et très
prégnante la commission des affaires
européennes que j'ai l'honneur de
présider à désigner trois rapporteurs il
y a Florence blatrix compta André
gatolin et Catherine Morin de Sailly sur
le règlement que la Commission
européenne propose pour créer un cadre
législatif européen commun sur la
liberté des médias l'objectif est
louable garantir l'indépendance des
médias notamment en contrôlant les
concentrations entre organes de presse
le texte instituerait pour cela un
comité de régulation européen chargé de
préserver le pluralisme du paysage
médiatique européen ce qui est assez
novateur par rapport à notre propre
système national de régulation des
médias nous rapporteurs reviendrons dans
un instant en introduction de cette
table ronde sur le contenu de ce texte
et ses enjeux sur lesquels il est
crucial pour nous législateur d'échanger
avec vous professionnelle de la presse
écrite et en ligne en partant de votre
expérience de votre vécu de vos
aspirations et de vos souhaits c'est
l'objectif de cette table ronde
permettez-moi auparavant de rappeler que
la commission des affaires européennes
du Sénat après préalablement contrôler
la conformité de cette proposition
législative européenne au principe de
subsidiarité en effet les traités
fondateurs européens confient au
Parlement nationaux le soin de vérifier
que l'Union européenne reste bien dans
son rôle intervient à bon escient et
évite l'excès de réglementation à ce
titre la commission que je préside
reçoit toutes les propositions
législatives de la Commission européenne
et l'examine sous cet angle la plupart
respectent la répartition des
compétences entre l'Union européenne et
ses États membres fixés dans les traités
mais il arrive que ce ne soit pas le cas
nous proposons alors au Sénat de le
dénoncer en adoptant un avis motivé qui
alerte sur le risque que l'Union
européenne aille trop loin dans ses
compétences
c'est ce que nous avons jugé utile de
faire concernant cette initiative sur
une régulation européenne de la liberté
des médias notre commission a donc
adopté à l'unanimité une proposition
d'avis motivé qui est devenue résolution
définitive du Sénat le 11 décembre
dernier selon nous en effet le texte
présenté par la Commission européenne
n'est pas conforme à ce praticide de
prudence et d'équilibre qui doit borner
les initiatives du législateur européen
et préserver la marge de manœuvre des
parlements nationaux nos rapporteurs
reviendront sans doute sur les motifs de
cette décision qui ne contestent
nullement les intentions les objectifs
ou le font même du texte mais qui
discutent sa valeur ajoutée par rapport
à un cadre législatif national déjà très
développé en France et qui interroge sa
base sa base juridique la Commission
européenne fondant son initiative sur le
seuil article 114 du traité sur le
fonctionnement de l'Union européenne
destiné à assurer le fonctionnement du
marché intérieur or s'il existe un
marché intérieur des médias en Europe
celui-ci n'échappe pas une segmentation
nationale culturelle et linguistique qui
justifient tout autant d'invoquer
l'article 176 du même traité lequel
appelle au respect de la diversité
culturelle et des législations
nationales cela méritait d'être souligné
par le Sénat à présent nous sommes très
heureux de démarrer avec vous ce matin
et en commun avec la commission culture
et son président Laurent Lafont l'examen
au fond de ce projet de règlement
européen qui aura sans doute de profonde
répercussions sur votre secteur Laurent
merci monsieur le Président cher
Jean-François en effet avec le président
de la commission des affaires
européennes nous avons souhaité ce matin
consacrer une matinée à ce texte
important sur la liberté des médias en
Europe ce règlement dit européen médias
freedom Act c'est une méthode que nous
avons bien ici au Sénat à savoir
anticiper et non pas subir la
législation européenne et je remercie la
commission tes affaires européennes pour
le choix de cette thématique et le
travail qui va vous être présenté dans
un instant par la rapporteur qui a donné
lieu à cette résolution le projet dont
nous allons débattre recoupe largement
plusieurs enjeux sur lequel la
commission de la culture a eu à se
prononcer ces dernières années je vais
pas les rappeler de manière exhaustive
mais en plus des travaux de notre
rapporteur que je cherchais du regard
Michel legier rapporteur pour les
budgétaires pour les sur la presse je
pense en particulier aux travaux que qui
avait mené Catherine Morin de saillie
travaux pionniers sur le sujet sur la
régulation dans le secteur du numérique
et la lutte contre les fausses
informations et la haine en ligne
qui sont des préoccupations partagées au
niveau du continent bien entendu je
pense également à la loi adopter sur les
droits voisins des éditeurs et des
agences de presse qui constituent la
transposition française du d'une
directive nous avons eu l'occasion d'en
parler avec certains d'entre vous à
plusieurs reprises et enfin à la
commission d'enquête sur la
concentration des des médias
David hassouline en était le rapporteur
et j'en étais le président commission
qui a travaillé l'année dernière et qui
a établi un
panorama panorama pardon très large dans
toute l'Europe des différences approches
mais également des convergences sur ces
problématiques ces sujets constituent le
cœur même du projet de règlement
européen sur lequel nous allons débattre
ce matin cependant tel que tel quel des
projets posent en effet de redoutable
difficulté le président rappain vient de
les rappeler elles sont d'ordre
juridique comme la commission des
affaires européennes la relevée dans en
adoptant le 8 décembre dernier la
proposition de résolution de Florence
blatrix contact Catherine Morin de
saillie et d'André gatelin qui soulève
une sérieuse réserve sur la base
juridique du texte mais les difficultés
relèvent également des principes dans
quelle mesure le projet de règlement
est-il compatible avec les fondements de
notre droit et je pense en particulier à
la loi de 1881 et également à celle de
1986 sur l'audiovisuel
je remercie nos intervenants à qui nous
allons donner la parole dans quelques
instants mais avant nous allons donner
la parole à
rapporteur de la commission des affaires
européennes pour qu'il présente leur
résolution on fait comme ça
Jean-François
on vous donne la parole je vous
présenterai après alors dans un
merci monsieur le Président Messieurs
les Présidents mesdames Messieurs mes
chers collègues nous entamons avec cette
audition collective dont je me réjouis
l'examen au fond d'un texte dense touffu
et complexe la proposition de règlement
du Parlement européen et du Conseil du
16 septembre 2022 qui a pour objet
d'établir un cadre européen comment de
régulation de l'ensemble du secteur du
média porté par la vice-présidence de la
Commission européenne chargée des
valeurs et de la transparence madame
bérailles et le commissaire français au
marché intérieur Monsieur Thierry Breton
il met en oeuvre l'engagement politique
pris par la présidence madame Ursula
vanderlione qui avait annoncé cette
initiative dans son discours sur l'état
de l'Union de 2021 d'indiquer les médias
ne sont pas des entreprises comme les
autres leur indépendance est essentielle
voilà pourquoi l'Europe a besoin d'une
loi qui garantit cette indépendance
l'année prochaine nous présenterons
précisément une telle loi sur la liberté
des médias elle a figuré effectivement
dans le programme de travail de la
commission pour 2022 donc elle prolonge
un paquet de mesures cela a été dit
destiné d'une part à réguler le cadre
d'exercice des services numériques et
des services des médias et d'autres
parts à défendre la liberté de la presse
conformément au plan d'action de la
Commission européenne pour la démocratie
européenne tout en établissant un
nouveau cadre législatif commun et
harmoniser d'un marché intérieur des
services de médias c'est donc un texte
aux objectifs louables ambitieux mais
disparate cela a été dit nous partageons
l'objectif principal de cette nouvelle
proposition de législation européenne il
s'agit au vu des constats qui ont pu
être fait depuis quelques années dans
quelques pays de l'Union européenne
récemment notamment en Pologne en
Hongrie de renforcer la liberté et
l'indépendance éditoriale des
entreprises de médias en recommandant
des financements dédiés aux médias de
services publics des mesures sur
l'attribution équit ables et
transparente de la publicité des règles
sur la transparence de la propriété des
organes de presse et un contrôle
déconcentrations ce texte institut pour
cela un comité de régulation européen
qui jouerait également un rôle
spécifique dans la lutte contre la
désinformation ce comité se
substituerait au groupe des régulateurs
européens pour les services de médias
audiovisuel larga
institué par la directive SMA et il
aurait compétence pour protéger toutes
les entreprises de médias contre des
mesures nationales injustifiées
disproportionné et discriminatoire afin
de préserver le pluralisme d'un paysage
médiatique européen de garantir son bon
fonctionnement et de renforcer la
protection de l'État de droit que cette
préoccupation que cette inquiétude que
cette nécessité d'agir soit largement
partagée au niveau européen cela ne fait
guère de doute mais comme vient de
l'indiquer le président rappain la base
juridique de l'article 114 destiné à
assurer le fonctionnement optimal du
marché intérieur des services de médias
nous a paru contestables en effet la
plupart des pays européens ont mis en
place de longues dates des règles
spécifiques nationales pour réguler le
secteur et particulièrement dans notre
pays comme bien le dire de le préciser
le président Lafont ne nous y trompons
pas la positions européennes proposent
un nouvel accroissement du champ des
compétences matérielles du législateur
européen au détriment des Parlement
nationaux ce constat est au cœur de
notre avis motivé sur la non conformité
au principe de subsidiarité je vais
laisser mon collègue André pour suivre
merci Florence en effet notre grande loi
sur la presse la loi du 29 juillet
1989 1980 devrait au terme de de ce
texte il était adopté sans doute être
amendé et dans son état actuel puisque
si des dispositions notamment des
articles 4 et des articles 6 l'article 4
et celui qui élargit la protection des
sources des journalistes et c'est une
bonne chose l'article 6 celui qui se
réfère à un indépendance éditoriale donc
nous aurions à réviser ces ce texte
fondamental c'est pas un problème en soi
et ça serait même plutôt une bonne chose
en termes d'apport mais il reste quand
même des un point qui nous semble dans
le libellé actuel de du projet de
règlement
quelques interrogations notamment ces
articles mettent en jeu la
responsabilité pénale de ce qui est
appelé les chefs de rédaction
terminologie donc proposé par la
Commission qui demanderait d'ailleurs
être précisé au regard du droit français
puisque nous parlons plutôt de directeur
de la publication en matière de
responsabilité juridique il y a
également dans ce cadre un point
d'interrogation on pourrait même dire
peut-être de suspicion quand elle a
validité d'un tel règlement de fait le
cadre européen qui est envisagé ici par
la commission s'inspire quasi
exclusivement de la réglementation
audiovisuelle au lieu de reconnaître les
spécificités sectorielles de la presse
le texte vise à les soumettre à quatre
communs avec l'audiovisuel or s'il est
possible dans une certaine mesure de
justifier l'existence d'un marché
technique dans l'Union européenne pour
les services audiovisuels et nous a paru
plus contestable de postuler l'existence
d'un marché européen pour la presse
compte tenu de l'importance des
différences culturelles et linguistiques
entre les États membres et là ça a été
rappelé la balle juridique utilisée est
celle de l'article 114 du traité de
fonctionnement de l'Union européenne
donc est celui qui gère le marché unique
alors que nous avons aussi d'autres
articles le 167 qui traite de la
diversité culturelle le premier est de
compétences exclusives de l'Union mais
de la commission le second est une
compétence partagée on sent bien qu'à
une volonté je dirais de la commission
d'utiliser la base juridique qui lui
donne le plus de pouvoir mais dans un
champ et dans une approche évidemment
plus économique et plus marché que débat
public ou respect de la diversité
culturelle par ailleurs nous nous
interrogeons sur l'articulation de ce
texte avec trois les trois principaux
textes européens qui constituent la base
de laquis communautaire en matière de
régulation des médias le premier c'est
naturellement la directive sur les
services médias audiovisuels la
directive s-ma il y a également la
directive établissant des règles sur
l'exercice du droit d'auteur et des
droits voisins applicables à certaines
transmissions en ligne d'organismes de
radio Diffusion et de retransmission de
programme de télévision et de radio
c'est la fameuse directive Capsa 2 qui
nous concerne moins puisque là on est
dans le débat plutôt concernant la
presse écrite et enfin le règlement
relatif au marché unique des services
numériques le DSA la proposition nous
examinons aujourd'hui est en effet très
apprécié dans son articulation avec la
directive SMA qu'elle est censée
pourtant prolonger en tous les cas selon
les dires de la Commission européenne or
les définitions proposées devraient être
intrigue rarement harmonisé avec celle
de la directive et en particulier pour
les services de médias mais aussi pour
les notions de responsabilité et de
décision éditoriale l'article 6 du
règlement qui concerne notamment le
niveau de protection applicable au
fournisseur de services médias et
d'actualité ne tient aucun compte des
dispositions existantes dans ce domaine
dans la directive SMCA il en va de même
des dispositions obligatoires sur
l'organisation éditoriale des médias aux
articles 7 et suivants qui portent sur
le rôle des autorités de régulation
ces articles prévoient la création d'un
comité européen au passage d'ailleurs
nous sommes inquiétés de la traduction
du terme de la première formulation qui
parle en anglais de board qui exprime un
conseil mais beaucoup plus puissant donc
un comité et un board ce n'est pas tout
à fait la même chose en tous les cas
c'est l'équivalence qui a donné pour
l'instant la Commission à ces deux
termes
et cette proposition de règlement du
coût modifie de façon importante
l'équilibre entre les autorités
nationales et les autorités européennes
tout en prévoyant que la Commission
européenne en assure le secrétariat au
niveau européen cet évidemment l'un de
nos points de vigilance essentielle
quand à la comptabilité compatibilité
pardon avec le DSA l'article 17 la
proposition de règlement prévoit un
nouveau mécanisme destiné à éviter une
double modération des contenus publiés
ou édités par les médias de fait il
acheteur une obligation pour les
fournisseurs de très grandes plateformes
de mettre à disposition des utilisateurs
un formulaire de déclaration en tant que
fournisseur de services de média afin de
bénéficier de modalités de modération
spécifique il s'agit là encore d'une
modification significative des
dispositions du DSA alors que ce dernier
n'est même pas encore entré en
application
il est indispensable je crois de lever
ces ambiguïtés pour coordonner et
articuler cette proposition avec le DSA
qui vient d'être adopté il nous a donc
semblé que dans son projet la Commission
européenne allait un peu trop loin et un
peu trop vite dans son ambition
législative en assimilant la régulation
des médias locaux et culturels de presse
au développement d'un marché intérieur
des médias dans l'audiovisuel et le
numérique il importe enfin de rappeler
en ma qualité de Sénator membres de
l'Assemblée parlementaire du Conseil de
l'Europe la PCE le rôle de cette
institution auprès de laquelle
d'ailleurs l'Association des
journalistes européens que vous
représentez ici à chère Catherine André
et reconnu comme observateur en effet le
Conseil de l'Europe a adopté plusieurs
conventions je crois très pertinentes
dans le domaine de la protection du
pluralisme et de la liberté des médias
la PCE est très active pour ne citer que
deux exemple relativement récents elle
adoptait en janvier 2020 une résolution
sur les menaces sur la liberté des
médias et la sécurité des journalistes
en Europe et en juin 2022 une résolution
sur le contrôle de la communication en
ligne une menace pour le pluralisme des
médias la liberté d'information et la
dignité humaine et là la présence
proposition de règlement ne mentionne
nullement le Conseil de l'Europe néglige
d'encourager l'Union européenne et ses
États membres à coopérer avec cette
institution particulièrement attentive
au respect des droits des journalistes
et des médias c'est pourquoi nous avons
dans notre avis motivé inclut cette
référence lorsque nous l'avons adopté en
décembre dernier nous avons maintenant
hâte de vous entendre et d'échanger avec
vous sur vos réactions vos analyses vos
expériences par rapport à ce projet je
vous remercie merci vous voyez que à ce
stade le projet de règlement soulève de
nombreuses questions de l'autre côté et
je ne doute pas qu'elle vous interroge
aussi et bien sûr nous sommes très
heureux comme André gatelin vient de le
dire de vous entendre et d'échanger avec
vous avant de vous donner la parole je
vais quand même vous présenter en
commençant par Jean-Pierre de keraoul
président de sogemmedia président de
l'Association européenne des éditeurs et
de la commission juridique de l'alliance
de la presse d'information générale la
pige madame Cécile Dubois qui est
cofondatrice et rédactrice de en chef de
94 citoyens et qu'au président du
Syndicat de la presse indépendante
d'information en ligne Le Spiel Monsieur
Patrick Evenot président d'observatoire
de la déontologie de l'information non
corrigée alors si nous sommes trompés
a disparu quand a été créé le conseil de
déontologie journalistique et le
médiation que j'ai fondée dont j'étais
le président et donc je suis
ex-président de l'Observatoire et
ex-président du cdjm mais je reste
toujours et avant tout historien des
médias titulaires d'une chaire à la
Sorbonne même si maintenant je suis
professeur et mérite très bien merci
d'avoir corrigé Christophe de Loire qui
est président de reporter sans
frontières et président dans cette salle
pour ne pas en rajouter moi je suis
directeur général et secrétaire général
écoutez je crois ne pas me tromper en
disant que Madame Catherine André et
vice-présidente de l'Association des
journalistes européens et d'actrices en
chef adjointe d'alternative économique
co-fondatrice et directrice de Vox
Europe c'est exact merci vous m'avez
rattrapé dernier moment
sans plus tarder je vais vous donner la
parole je ne sais pas qui commence
monsieur
entendu à votre condense madame la
sénatrice mesdames les génératrices
Messieurs les Présidents et je fais
cours pour aller tout de suite au sujet
les éditeurs de presse européen
partagent évidemment le souci de la
Commission et non évidemment aucune
aucune réserve sur les intentions du
projet je crois que c'est un point qui
nous rassemble tous et je dirais que
prévenir les risques d'ingérence
extérieurs garantir l'indépendance des
médias assurer une meilleure
transparence on a évidemment aucun
problème là-dessus et sur plusieurs des
mesures envisagées dans le texte actuel
nous avons également aucune objection
pour autant que poursuive les objectifs
et effectivement mentionnés à l'instant
nous avons comme vous le savez vous avez
déjà évoqué trois sujets de
préoccupation principaux le premier
c'est le fameux article 6 qui
la rédaction actuelle avec effectivement
des difficultés un peu de traduction
revient à confier semble-t-il au
rédacteur en chef l'ensemble des
décisions éditoriales ce qui revient en
France par exemple à privé le directeur
de publications ce qui est en anglais de
pablisher de sa capacité effective à
diriger notre sentiment qui est je crois
quand même que l'affaire de bon sens
c'est qu'on ne peut pas disjoindre
l'autorité et la responsabilité dans
aucune situation donc si on demande
conformément à la loi de 1880 à au
directeur des publications d'être
civilement pénalement et personnellement
responsable de l'intégralité du contenu
de sa publication on ne peut pas le
priver d'un pouvoir d'intervention de
direction effective au quotidien de sa
publication j'ajoute par parenthèse que
comme vous le savez en France la loi
maintenant impose à toutes les
communication d'avoir une charte
éditoriale qui est préalablement négocié
entre les journalistes et l'éditeurs
donc de ce point de vue il nous semble
vraiment problématique de d'introduire
cette nouveauté qui serait qui
reviendrait en fait à 10 joindre
autorité et responsabilité et
effectivement nous contraindrait à
modifier la loi de 1880 donc
l'éditeur en réalité ne l'oublions pas
dans l'immense majorité des cas et je
conviens tout à fait qu'il peut y avoir
de temps en temps de malheureuse
exceptions mais dans l'immense majorité
des cas et je peux vous le dire en tant
qu'éditeur personnellement des
journalistes de dans la presse régionale
il est le premier défenseur de la
liberté de la presse et il est le
premier rempart de ces journalistes donc
donner le sentiment que il y a sur ces
sujets une sorte de conflit structurel
entre l'éditeur et le et les
journalistes est assez logiciel et
d'ailleurs il est frappant de voir que
dans le projet de texte nulle part je
dis bien nulle part on ne parle de
l'éditeur nulle part il y a publisher ou
éditeur on fait comme si le problème
était exclusivement entre des
actionnaires chez à odeuse et les
journalistes or en France et dans tous
les pays européens évidemment
l'entreprise de presse elle est pilotée
par un éditeur et qui en France a des
responsabilités extrêmement claires
voilà donc ça c'est c'est un sujet qu'il
faut qu'il faudra traiter effectivement
le fait que ça soit envisagé dans le cas
d'un règlement et problématique il est
envisagé comme vous savez aujourd'hui
c'est discuter au Parlement européen où
nous étions la semaine dernière
peut-être de
séparer le texte actuel en une version
qui se relèverait d'une directive et une
partie du règlement la difficulté si ça
reste un règlement c'est qu'il est
d'applications immédiate et que donc en
France par exemple nous n'aurions pas la
possibilité d'adapter les principes zéro
qui pourrait parfaitement être mis dans
une directive relative à l'indépendance
des rédactions des médias à la liberté
des journalistes etc on pourrait très
bien avoir des principes généraux qui
pourraient être traduit transposer dans
la loi française de telle sorte qu'il
reste compatible avec la loi 1880 mais
malheureusement si c'est un règlement ça
obligera à modifier deuxième difficulté
c'est l'article 17 ou les grandes
plateformes ont aujourd'hui le pouvoir
de modifier unilatéralement ou de
supprimer des contenus de presse qui est
évidemment parfaitement inacceptable
même si on envisage que ça soit après
avoir simplement informé le titre
ça pose de il y a deux difficultés la
première c'est qu'il faudrait que les
éditeurs des sites en question se
déclarent auprès des grandes plateformes
et que donc les se déclare en tant que
publication et que les grandes
plateformes seraient les juges en
réalité de ce qu'est de la presse et ce
qui est pas de la presse
bon c'est évidemment totalement
inacceptable qu'en fonction de l'humeur
de Monsieur musk qui est comme vous
savez assez variable d'un jour à l'autre
on puisse dire bah oui c'est celui-là
c'est de la presse puisque là c'est
c'est pas de la presse bon il y a aucune
légitimité à ça donc il faut trouver une
formule de labellisation c'est pas
simple parce que les situations sont
différentes d'un pays à l'autre en
France nous avons la chance d'avoir la
commission paritaire des publications et
agence de presse qui dit ce qui est de
la presse et ce qui est pas de la presse
et que nous venons de renforcer
récemment dans son autorité par exemple
avec des exigences d'emploi de
journalistes ce qui est très bien pour
valider qu'une entreprise de presse qui
prétendette mais effectivement il peut
pas y avoir nos yeux d'entreprises de
presse qui n'emploie pas de journalistes
donc cet instant de commission paritaire
qui a une légitimité politique et
professionnelle et elle est composée de
représentants des ministres et des
représentants des professionnels et elle
joue son rôle et il y a malheureusement
pas toujours l'équivalent dans les
autres
donc on dit en France labellisation
c'est très naturellement à la commission
paritaire s'il y a des équivalents dans
d'autres pays on pourrait considérer que
ce sont ces équivalents aussi qui
valides à défaut il peut y avoir
d'autres instances qui ont été évoqués
le JTI ou autre qui qui pourrait jouer
ce rôle à condition à nos yeux
qu'effectivement les éditeurs de presse
dans leur responsabilités ils souhaitent
associés parce qu'on peut difficilement
imaginer qu'une instance labellisante
n'est pas de légitimité à la fois
démocratique et professionnelle donc il
faut résoudre le problème de légitimité
mais nous éditeur de presse européen
nous sommes tout à fait ouverts à
différentes possibilités de
labellisation à condition que ce soit
pas des plateformes qui s'y substituent
évidemment il est deuxième point pas
acceptable que il y ait une décision
sans procédure contradictoire il va de
soi que si une plateforme considère
qu'elle doit supprimer un contenu de
presse euh qui serait contradict
contraire à ces Conditions Générales
d'Utilisation c'est pas c'est pas un
critère acceptable il faut qu'il y ait
une procédure contradictoire il faut
qu'elle informe de son intention de
suppression à l'éditeur et que l'éditeur
et la possibilité de répondre et qu'à
défaut est qu'à défaut ça soit le juge
judiciaire qui tranche et non pas la
plateforme comme dans la version
actuelle dernier point le fameux Conseil
européen des médias je serai bref là
dessus il nous semble que dans son sa
définition actuelle il a pas vraiment de
justification à s'occuper de la faire de
presse écrite autant comme vous l'avez
indiqué Monsieur le Président il peut se
justifier quand on parle d'audiovisuel
en matière de presse écrite on voit pas
bien qu'elle serait sa compétence et
j'ai d'ailleurs remarqué que l'arcom qui
serait supposé être notre représentant
français au sein du Board a bien fait
savoir qu'elle souhaitait absolument pas
elle n'a pas de compétences en matière
de presse et elle souhaite absolument
pas en avoir au total je crois que il
faut pas mettre en place des mauvaises
solutions pour résoudre devrait problème
oui il y a des problèmes de liberté de
la presse oui il y a des journalistes
menacés oui dans certains pays européens
la liberté de la presse n'est pas
respectée nous avons eu récemment même
en France avec le cas d'un hebdo en
Bretagne des menaces sur des menaces de
mort sur des journalistes donc nous
éditeurs de presse sommes totalement
solidaires de nos journalistes
évidemment pour protéger leur liberté et
leur capacité à exercer leur métier mais
n'invantons pas un marché intérieur des
de la presse écrite qui n'existe pas
pour résoudre ce problème
ne n'oublions pas que la vraie menace
sur l'économie de la presse aujourd'hui
c'est la puissance considérable des
grandes plateformes et que donc le vrai
sujet c'est comment on rééquilibre cette
puissance entre les grandes plateformes
et les éditeurs de presse qui soit
digitaux écrits ou les deux
et donc enfin quand il s'agit de liberté
de la presse
n'imaginons pas que on l'a on
l'améliorera en séparant les éditeurs
des journalistes l'éditeur comme je le
disais il est le premier rempart des
journalistes on est ensemble face à un
tel défi démocratique industrielle
professionnelle dans le déséquilibre de
puissance entre les grandes plateformes
et la presse que c'est vraiment pas le
moment ni les uns ni les autres d'avoir
des postures nous devons nous battre
ensemble journaliste et éditeur pour
sauver la presse la renouveler et lui
permettre de jouer son rôle au service
de la démocratie
madame Cécile Dubois
c'est bon oui merci
nous on trouve ce règlement alors on
partage globalement les lignes rouges
que vous avez évoqué un certain nombre
de lignes rouges que vous avez évoquées
on trouve malgré tout ce règlement quand
même très intéressant dans ces dans ces
objets c'est à dire se protéger de
gouvernement libéraux de régimes
libéraux il y en a plusieurs en Europe
et on n'est pas à l'abri même en France
un jour de se retrouver dans un régime
il libéral et donc il n'est pas
inintéressant en France de s'interroger
à cette possible configuration qui
puisse arriver un jour et donc de voir
comment aussi en France on pourrait se
prémunir d'un éventu de l'arrivée
éventuelle d'un régime libéral et
comment l'Europe pourrait peut-être nous
aider en ce sens donc même si on est
très protégé même si on a d'excellents
lois comme la loi de 1881 qui reste un
pilier c'est pas inintéressant et
l'autre point c'est le dialogue avec les
plateformes ça reste évidemment aussi un
très gros sujet pour nous c'est l'un des
principaux sujets ce sont les
plateformes avec lesquelles il est
extrêmement difficile d'avoir un
dialogue puisque c'est forcément
complètement
disproportant on n'est pas du tout dans
les mêmes dans les mêmes rapports de
force même un syndicat d'éditeur
vis-à-vis d'une plateforme même
plusieurs syndicats d'éditeurs au niveau
d'un pays c'est extrêmement compliqué
en ce sens le règlement nous semble
apporter des des pistes intéressantes et
à commencer par ce super comité qui qui
ambitionne de développer un dialogue
peut-être un peu plus suivi aussi avec
les plateformes qui ne soit pas
seulement un règlement de temps en temps
avec des décisions coupées mais
peut-être la possibilité d'un dialogue
constructif avec les plateformes
auxquelles
à participer
les tous les pays les éditeurs les
syndicats d'éditeurs la réserve qu'on a
par rapport à ce à ce super comité c'est
qu'effectivement comme vous l'avez
rappelé c'est ça se présente comme un
super comité vous avez rappelé monsieur
sénateur que le la proposition du
règlement était même que le secrétariat
soit assuré par la Commission européenne
donc là vraiment on se dit que c'est
complètement téléguidé par la Commission
européenne et c'est un problème là on
est on est complètement d'accord donc ce
je parle je profite pour rappeler que le
Spil fait partie d'une d'une association
européenne qui s'appelle news media
Europe qui a fait un certain nombre de
propositions un certain nombre
d'amendements et cette association a
fait à proposer notamment comme
amendement de d'intégrer des éditeurs
des représentants d'éditeurs des
représentants de syndicats d'éditeurs ou
d'associations d'éditeurs dans ce super
comité dans la gouvernance de ce super
commun
souscrivons complètement
l'élargir cette gouvernance non
seulement aux autorités locales mais
aussi à des à des représentants des des
éditeurs nous semblerait peut-être de
nature à rééquilibrer un peu le pouvoir
de ce comité et en tout cas bien
évidemment son secrétariat ne doit pas
être assuré par la Commission européenne
mais il doit vraiment avoir être
indépendant dans sa dans son
fonctionnement
concernant les les l'autre lignes rouges
on partage
quasiment entièrement aussi avec avec
Jean-Pierre de karaudes c'est
évidemment l'article 6a et
l'indépendance la manière dont il est
actuellement rédigé d'indépendance des
rédactions et c'est même au-delà de
l'indépendance des rédactions c'est
rédigé d'une manière qui laisse entendre
que le rédacteur en chef peut prendre
des décisions individuelles et que
l'éditeur n'a rien à y voir ce qui pose
vraiment vraiment là un problème
un problème dans l'organisation le bon
fonctionnement d'une rédaction de
problèmes principaux comme la comme l'a
rappelé Jean-Pierre de chaos le problème
juridique c'est que on a une loi 1880
qui protège les journalistes grâce
justement aux éditeurs qui portent le
chapeau le directeur de publication qui
porte juridiquement qui porte la
responsabilité juridique des propos des
textes du contenu des journalistes donc
il est absolument nécessaire de
préserver ça et puis sur le plan
financier tout simplement aussi c'est
très déjà très compliqué pour la presse
un secteur qui est fragile donc
fragiliser les éditeurs en en
les empêchant de pouvoir
maîtriser leurs lignes éditoriale ça
couperait définitivement
l'investissement dans toutes les
entreprises de presse donc c'est
vraiment la fin
d'un financement pérenne de la presse et
ce serait d'ailleurs complètement non
productif puisque finalement
il y aurait des influences qui
s'exprimeraient autrement c'est à dire
que il n'empêche pas non plus de on peut
toujours virer son rédaction donc
l'influence finalement s'exprimerait
autrement et ça n'aurait même pas
forcément une efficacité très grande
l'amendement qu'on a auquel on souscrit
qui a été porté par un news media Europe
sur cet article 6a c'est de de permettre
une certaine marge de manœuvre
de permettre des décisions et de marge
de manœuvre bien évidemment de la
rédaction mais dans le cadre d'une ligne
éditoriale décidé avec l'éditeur enfin
décidé par l'éditeur c'est à dire c'est
la ligne éditoriale de l'éditeur c'est
lui qui porte le média et
partant de là la rédaction ensuite à sa
marge de manœuvre dans le fonctionnement
actuel des médias l'éditeur il est pas
tout le temps derrière leur rédaction
pour regarder ce qu'il écrit en revanche
dans cette dans ce même article 6 le 6b
nous semble très intéressant et là nous
nous écrivons complètement c'est de
prévenir les conflits d'intérêt et
d'être de garantir la révélation de tout
conflit d'intérêt réel ou potentiel ça
ça nous semble vraiment quelque chose
d'utile nous avons lors de la de
l'audition sur la concentration des
médias nous devions-nous attirer
l'attention sur les le fait que le
problème en France n'est pas tant la
concentration des médias mais le fait
que les médias beaucoup de médias
appartiennent à des groupes qui dont
l'activité principale n'est pas
n'est pas la presse mais tout autre
chose
des armes au Télécom et donc les
conflits d'intérêt dans ce type de
situation peuvent exister donc avoir un
garde-fou par rapport à ces conflits
d'intérêts nous semble aussi très
intéressant par rapport aux
plateformes aussi
il a été rappelé ce problème de de
retrait des contenus unilatéral par les
plateformes là-dessus nous souscrivons
nous souscrivons à ce qui a été dit
concernant
la nécessité d'avoir un dialogue avec
les enfin de pouvoir réagir et de d'être
considéré
comme de la presse alors vous avez
Jean-Pierre decarol a rappelé la
question de bien reconnaître les titres
de presse en vertu en France de la cPPA
P on rajoute une chose nous on a dans la
loi de 801
la loi de 80 c'est la liberté
d'expression de tous les citoyens pas
seulement de la presse c'est à dire que
la loi de 81 elle ne distingue pas des
titres de presse la loi de 80 c'est
vraiment l'expression des citoyens des
éditeurs des citoyens et et là c'est
pour nous un petit le problème que pose
que poserait en fait le traitement
prioritaire des médias au delà même de
distinguer les médias est-ce que c'est
un média cPPA P ou pas qui
certes est important c'est important
aussi de de pouvoir
de veiller à ce que un
citoyen ou un lanceur d'alerte qui
s'exprime sur des plateformes ne puisse
pas voir son contenu retiré d'une
manière unilatérale et qu'il est lui
aussi le moyen une instance pour réagir
qu'il y ait lui aussi droit à une
procédure contradictoire
et juste pour insister sur ce point du
rapport avec les plateformes là-dessus
malgré tout ce règlement mais vraiment
l'accent sur quelque chose qui est
absolument nécessaire c'est que nous
avons en France un problème enfin dans
tous les pays nous avons un énorme
problème avec les plateformes c'est
qu'elles sont totalement soustafées dans
les pays pour pouvoir réagir par rapport
à ces questions de contenu nous avons
nous des éditeurs plusieurs éditeurs qui
ont eu des problèmes de de compte
pirater de compte enfin des tas de
problèmes et qui ne peuvent pas avoir
d'interlocuteur dans les plateformes
parce que il y a une personne qui est
censée être relation avec les médias une
personne qui est censée mais en fait ces
personnes là sont toutes seules pour
tout le pays donc elles sont évidemment
pas du tout disponibles donc même si on
peut avoir év leur téléphone portable ça
sert strictement à rien elle ne
répondront jamais et donc là on a
vraiment un problème peut-être que
au-delà même de ce règlement la France
pourrait légiférer pour exiger d'avoir
un interlocuteur un interlocuteur pour
les médias et un interlocuteur aussi
pour tous les citoyens enfin il faut que
les citoyens qui voient leur contusurper
qui voient leur contenu supprimer d'une
manière totalement arbitraire puisse
réagir je pense que j'ai déjà parlé
longtemps donc j'arrêterai là on a
d'autres beaucoup d'autres marques mais
c'était vraiment les points essentiels
alors pour la déontologie Monsieur
Patrick merci
voilà merci monsieur le Président bon je
recommence pas les formules de politesse
évidemment il y a un trouble dans les
andains comme aurait dit
Boris Vian et que les sénateurs
connaissent bien parce que les andains
ce sont les
les raies de de foin que l'on coupe et
qui sont parallèles je parle pour les
représentants des provinces françaises
qui connaissent bien cela il y a un
trouble dans les andains pourquoi
premièrement parce que l'Europe veut
appliquer
le même système à trois ensembles
démocratiques différents d'un côté les
démocraties il libérales de l'Europe de
l'Est et se sont elles qui sont visées
en premier évidemment et évidemment
qu'il faut faire quelque chose pour Léon
roi pour etc etc bien mais il y a cela
ou le pouvoir est où les oligarques
contrôlent de fait les médias en entend
absolument entre les deux et donc là où
il y a un vrai problème et où l'Europe
veut agir mais ne peut pas agir ce
dirigeant directement contre un pays
essaie de d'assimiler à l'ensemble
deuxièmement il y a les démocraties
libérales classique qu'on pourrait
mettre dans l'Europe du Nord l'Allemagne
etc où il y a évidemment pas de problème
bon quelques-uns de temps en temps il y
a forcément toujours des problèmes
humains trop humain mais bon et puis les
démocraties libérales instables
je les appelle comme ça je mettrai
dedans la France et l'Italie
qui sont sur des
qui sont entre les deux quoi pour
l'instant bon puis on pourrait peut-être
en mettre l'autre alors comment
conjuguer comment concilier comment
aligner la Hongrie l'Allemagne et la
France
OK
bien ceci d'autant plus que
l'Europe enfin le règlement
considère que
le marché des médias est européen alors
que pas du tout il est soit complètement
international les grandes plateformes
Murdoch tout ce que vous voulez
bertolsman bon soit il est très peu
européen j'ai essayé de recenser il y a
Rosel qui est franco-belge OK
quelques intérêts un petit peu partout
un petit peu partout mais qui se tourne
de plus en plus de vers les États-Unis
bertolsman qui ceux qui cherchent à se
retirer de tout et malheureusement
nous l'Autorité de la concurrence n'a
pas accepté qu'il vende RTL et M6 à TF1
ce qui leur a permis de se débarrasser
media info
invest de crétinski qui qui est à cheval
sur la Tchéquie et sur sur la France et
puis Mediaset
Berlusconi Italie Espagne et vivent un
dit mais pas Vivendi Canal+ seulement
qui qui rayonne sur mes quitte un pôle
de divertissement uniquement et qui
n'exporte que Canal+ mais qui n'exporte
pas
C8 cnews heureusement
ils ont pas encore trouvé le Hanouna
polonais mais ils vont finir par le
trouver
bien il y a donc la véritable il y a une
véritable question de on sent bien que
la
les rédacteurs de ce règlement sont
embêtés parce qu'ils veulent évidemment
viser les
îles libéraux d'abord et préserver alors
bon deuxième point et c'est ce qui
marque évidemment le plus c'est le
Comité européen pour les services de
médias
alors mes collègues
surtout Jean-Pierre je t'appelle
Jean-Pierre depuis des années
évidemment va hurler d'après ce que je
vais dire mais bon constituer par les
régulateurs nationaux de visuels les
regards etc pourquoi pourquoi laisser de
côté la presse
à l'heure de la convergence généralisée
où tout le monde presse radio télé
internet fait de la presse radio télé
internet je dis toujours à mes amis de
la presse que un jour où je l'autre
l'arcom va s'emparer de vos podcasts
puisque
théoriquement les podcasts devraient
être régis par la com pourquoi pas à
l'heure de la convergence généralisée on
va voir pourquoi il y a pas on fait tout
pourquoi ne pas adjoindre à cette
ergat transformé
les conseils de presse ou de déontologie
et c'est là en sens là que je prêche
évidemment pour ma boutique vous l'avez
bien compris comme chacun ici prêche
pousse pour sa boutique bon
faut être clair vous le connaissez vous
avez l'habitude des lobbies donc
je prêche pour ma boutique il faut y
intégrer les conseils de presse il y a
20 conseils de presse en Europe
dans l'Union européenne sur 27 pays il
suffirait on peut imaginer un comité
européen pour les services des médias
détachés de la commission complètement
indépendante avec
trois ensembles le les regards
transformés ou pas transformés les
l'aipce l'Association internationale des
sessions européennes des conseils de
presse et puis et moi j'y tiens beaucoup
des personnalités qualifiées
indépendantes des chercheurs des
universitaires des cultura je parle pas
pour moi je veux pas en faire partie
c'est pas du tout mon problème je suis
pas dans ce cas-là mais on pourrait
avoir ces trois collèges qui pourraient
être à géométrie valable et là on
pourrait vraiment discuter de l'ensemble
de ce qui pose problème dans la liberté
des des médias des rédactions etc
bon petite analyse de texte laquelle je
me suis livré bêtement comme ça
j'ai pris des mots alors par exemple
régulation cité 154 fois dans les et
l'autorégulation seulement 18 fois
vous voyez on veut la régulation
forcément les regards l'arcom a un
pouvoir de coercition que n'ont pas les
conseils de presse qui n'ont que un
neiman shame
l'indépendance cité 129 fois le
pluralisme 73 73 fois mais ils ne se
font pas partie des définitions de
l'article 2 du règlement on ne définit
pas à l'indépendance on ne définit pas
le pluralisme
est-ce que c'est le pluralisme interne
est-ce que c'est le pluralisme externe
est-ce que c'est l'indépendance
des médias des journalistes de de quoi
est-ce que si je puis dire je fais les
usages des consommateurs aucune
occurrence les
usages n'existent pas dans cette
réglementation c'est un peu étonnant
la convergence 11 occurrence seulement
c'est aussi un peu un problème et puis
on va être quasiment sur un pied
d'égalité entre la liberté et la
concentration liberté cité 62 fois
seulement
62 fois seulement en 50 et je sais pas
combien de pages la concentration
comment
et la concentration 54 fois et là il y a
évidemment
quelque chose qui est par exemple au
paragraphe vin la ligne éditoriale a
fait l'objet d'un accord entre les
propriétaires et les chefs de rédaction
c'est un tout petit peu simpliste
c'est faire fi de la nature même des
médias les médias sont des objets
tripartites c'est-à-dire à la fois une
entreprise
détenue par un ou plusieurs actionnaires
une rédaction
et un public et je l'ai déjà dit pour
quand j'étais auditionné vous souvenez
monsieur Lafont sur
sur la concentration mais tant qu'on
tient pas compte de ça on ne comprend
rien aux médias
c'est le paragraphe 40 les articles 21
22 qui portent sur la concentration
reflète sur ce sur ce sujet une pensée
particulièrement indigente je le
maintiens il y a il y est entretenu une
confusion permanente entre concentration
et menaces sur l'indépendance et le
pluralisme
par exemple le droit de refuser
l'arrivée d'un nouvel actionnaire
et la viabilité des entreprises
si les journalistes du Monde avaient
refusé l'arrivée de berger pigasnier le
fait en 2010 ils auraient mis la clé
sous la porte bon
monsieur Venou je vais vous demander de
raccourcir un petit peu
j'ai presque fini
évidemment évidemment il arrive voire
Bolloré que des actionnaires soient
toxiques mais ils ne sont pas tous même
quand ils sont concentrés toxiques c'est
là où il y avait véritablement une
confusion bon voir la commission que
vous avez présidé monsieur Lafont donc
on va pas y revenir mais et puis c'est
pas forcément une question de
concentration Monsieur Nicolas Barré
directeur de la rédaction de des échos
qui se fait virer par son propriétaire
enfin c'est pas le propriétaire mais
c'est le l'éditeur comme dirait Monsieur
Jean-Pierre vêtu de keraoud mais
l'éditeur il est sous la houlette du
propriétaire
directement comme ça c'est pas une
question de concentration Bernard
Arnault il a un tout petit groupe de
médias 300 millions d'euros de chiffre
d'affaires 300
000 exemplaires vendus chaque jour
entre les deux quotidiens
c'est un tout petit groupe de médias
c'est pas de la concentration ou bien
alors il va falloir qu'on définisse de
concentration si bas que même même pour
atteindre Bolloré moi j'ai fait le
calcul Bolloré si on prend toutes les
audiences y compris du groupe la garder
ré Bolloré on atteint 9% d'audience
alors si on doit descendre en dessous de
9% l'audience pour bloquer Bolloré
d'abord on bloque toutes les capacités
de fusion future les capacités
d'absorption futures et ensuite il faut
heureusement les lois ne sont pas
rétroactives mais il faut à ce moment-là
des gommer TF1 et pourquoi pas France
Télévisions qui est à 30 % de l'audience
hein bon ça pose un vrai problème donc
il y a la véritablement je je vais en
conclure je vais conclure très
rapidement
il y a la véritablement un problème de
de
pour
on voit bien d'où ça vient on a toute
une série de personnes notamment en
France qui prône contre la concentration
etc ça sans voir que c'est l'important
c'est la toxicité éventuelle du
propriétaire ou de la concentration
c'est pas la concentration en elle-même
c'est même pas la propriété en elle-même
on peut être
vendeur d'avions de chasse et d'armement
comme le groupe d'assaut et garder le
Figaro comme il était avant et comme il
sera après c'est-à-dire un journal
conservateur de droite catholique machin
etc mais le journal n'a pas changé parce
que il a été racheté par Dassault bon
donc il faut bien voir que c'est même
pas une question de propriété c'est une
question alors comment définir la
toxicité là c'est un vrai problème
là c'est un vrai problème parce qu'on
voit bien qu'il y a une toxicité chez un
notamment pour ne pas le citer le groupe
Bolloré bon voilà
alors après il y a quelques petites
remarques comme ça je termine je termine
je termine juste
on parle d'information fiable et de
médias de qualité qui fera le distingo
le JTI mais moi je pense que le label
est parfaitement contre-productif à
partir du moment où vous mettez un label
vous ça veut dire que vous êtes du côté
pour ceux qui sont complotistes et
autres vous êtes du côté du pouvoir vous
êtes des donc par définition des
méchants parce que vous avez le label
on parle de réguler l'offre de contenu
médiatique
quid de la liberté évidemment il y a des
gens qui ne me plaisent pas dans
certaines télés dans certaines radios
dans certaines presses mais je pense
qu'il plaise à l'autre et la liberté
elle est au prix de la contradiction du
pluralisme de etc etc bon voilà alors
par contre effectivement sur les mesures
d'audience les publicités d'État
protection des sources oui oui toujours
oui pour les garde-fous à condition de
les mettre vraiment avec de peser avec
un trébuchet et avec finesse parce que
il faut faire très attention voir la
tripartition évoquée plus haut
enfin la transparence je vous rappelle
que dès 2009 j'avais proposé c'est dans
le le rapport du sénateur Michel
Thiolière du 4 novembre 2009 j'avais
proposé c'était une loi visant à réguler
la concentration dans le secteur des
médias déjà en 2009 après l'état général
de la presse j'avais proposé qu'on crée
un observatoire européen du pluralisme
et de la transparence dans les médias et
où on pourrait agglomérer toute une
série de choses mais je le tiens à votre
disposition j'ai déjà cité il est aussi
je suppose dans votre dans le rapport
Lafont à souligne merci de m'avoir
écouté monsieur Ève Nova sous un prisme
un peu plus international peut-être
demander à Monsieur Deloire donc de
s'exprimer maintenant alors je le dis en
préambule en essayant de respecter le
temps parce que ce qui va être important
aussi c'est l'échange je vais m'y
attacher
cette proposition de texte qui est
imparfaite suicide beaucoup de
scepticisme et pas seulement dans cette
salle de la part des l'Ender allemand
de la part cette dernière semaine des
éditeurs nordiques et leur association
de la part d'historien des médias
et sans doute y a-t-il effectivement sur
un certain nombre d'articles matières
à amendement
y compris sur des aspects évoqués par
Monsieur de keraoul ou madame Dubois
néanmoins il y a là une formidable
opportunité
et il me semble qu'il serait dommageable
que le Sénat
s'attache à une position défensive
aux dépens d'une position plus offensive
à un moment où clairement il y a un
enjeu majeur et où l'Union européenne
alors quelle que soit les espèces
juridiques que j'entends absolument mais
peut jouer un rôle
y a-t-il un marché intérieur des médias
européens moi j'aurais tendance à dire
le marché des médias n'existe plus
vraiment
au sens où les médias sont
sont enfin qu'est-ce qu'on entend par
média mais si on entend par média les
médias d'information les médias
producteurs de journalistes je crois que
c'est ce dont on parle ici
ces médias aujourd'hui produisent des
contenus qui se retrouvent dans l'espace
numérique en concurrence directe avec
des contenus produits par toutes sortes
de producteurs
propagande ferme atrol industrie de la
désinformation citoyens scientifiques
faisant des
vidéos passionnantes
corrupteur d'informations du positif du
négatif mais en tout cas une concurrence
de toutes sortes de contenu contre tous
les autres indistins
et le marché européen ou national
n'existe plus tellement au sens où
l'espace public désormais numérisé et
globalisées et n'a pas aujourd'hui de
frontières sauf celle mise par les
régimes d'esthétiques qui vise à clore
leur espace public et à l'intérieur à
contrôler l'information
et donc j'ai envie de vous dire prenons
l'occasion de ce texte et que le Sénat
dans le rapport qu'il produira prennent
l'occasion de ce texte pour poser une
vision de long terme et poser des
propositions qui peuvent changer la
donne
parce que si on regarde les évolutions
tendancielles le risque c'est que du
fait de l'organisation de l'écosystème
le financement des médias deviennent de
plus en plus difficiles c'est normal ils
sont en concurrence aujourd'hui déloyale
avec d'autres producteurs de contenu
que le
ce qu'on estime être le journaliste
si on ne le regarde que lui et si on
s'attache à le défendre mais sans tenir
compte du reste on finisse par ne
défendre une partie qui est en train de
s'effondrer
un certain nombre de points sur lequel
sur lesquels il y a matière soit
avancées soit
à amender 1 effectivement la question
des des de la définition des médias et
de leurs obligations
comment éviter la capture oligarchique
et quel que soit le rôle des éditeurs la
capture oligarchique le danger de la
capture oligarchique il est réel
donc s'il y a un certain nombre de
problèmes dans
la rédaction actuelle de l'article y
compris le problème de traduction
d'ailleurs sur la question des décisions
individuelles
qui de l'anglais vers le français
il y a matière à mettre en place des
processus pour garantir non pas
l'indépendance des rédactions mais
l'indépendance éditoriale du journaliste
et qu'il a est un enjeu majeur qui peut
passer par des aspects procédure
de processus ou par des mesures visant
par exemple à introduire des notions
telles que des formes de trafic
d'influence dans le champ de
l'information
on a formulé des propositions de ce
sujet la deuxième question qui est celle
du rapport au plateforme et je rejoins
Jean-Pierre dequerel ou sur ce point
qu'aujourd'hui les plateformes alors non
plus ou n'auront plus à partir du 1er
janvier 2024 au moment de la mise en
œuvre du DSA tous les droits mais le DSA
est plutôt orienté à supposer qu'il soit
bien
appliqué sur la distinction entre les
sites et l'illicites et pas tellement
sur l'organisation du chant du lycée
et où là l'article 17 aujourd'hui qui
prévoit simplement que les plateformes
feront tout leur possible pour prévenir
à l'avance de décision de modération
c'est un engagement dérisoire au regard
des enjeux la question c'est comment
fait-on pour que les plateformes d'une
certaine manière puisse protéger
l'information journalistique
puis même lui redonner une forme
d'avantage comment on peut amplifier la
fiabilité de l'information
et de ce point de vue là il y a besoin
de forme de distinction on a besoin les
différents intervenants évoqués on a
besoin aujourd'hui de distinguer ce qui
relève du journaliste ce qui n'en relève
pas et ça tous les parlements du monde
sont confrontés à ce sujet là si on fait
pas ça on n'arrivera pas à réintroduire
un mécanisme de promotion de la
fiabilité dans l'espace public
la journaliste initiative qui était cité
à plusieurs
occasions est un moyen non
discrétionnaire
sans organe qui décide qui est
journaliste qui ne l'est pas
[Musique]
est déjà cité
explicitement et implicitement dans le
projet de emfa
l'enjeu serait de donner obligation aux
plateformes d'utiliser des
mécanisme de promotion de la fiabilité
de l'information j'attire votre
attention sur une chose c'est qu'il y a
eu la Commission européenne à négocié
avec les plateformes numériques et
d'autres acteurs un code de conduite
contre la désinformation il y a un
engagement qui l'engagement numéro 22
qui est un engagement léger qui
demandait aux plateformes de mettre en
place des indicateurs de fiabilité de
l'information
ce texte a été négocié avec elle mais
les plateformes vous le savez pouvaient
signer tel ou tel engagement et ne pas
souscrire aux autres une seule sur les
14 possibles à souscrit cet engagement
on est aujourd'hui dans la situation les
plateformes numériques refusent de
prétendent mener des opérations contre
la désinformation sont en fait comme
vous le savez au moment même où il y a
des obligations des nouvelles
obligations du fait du DSA de licencier
toutes leurs équipes dites trust and
safety
celles qui devrait traiter de ces sujets
là c'est en train de se désarmer
et ne veulent pas surtout s'engager sur
ce qui est fondamental c'est que nos
espaces publics démocratiques ont été
construits parce qu'il y avait des
mécanismes à travers la régulation des
médias à travers l'autorégulation des
journalistes pour favoriser la fiabilité
de l'information et le MFA est vraiment
une occasion pour faire ça et ce serait
dommage de rater cette occasion
troisième chose
c'est l'occasion aussi le MFA de mettre
en place avec un mécanisme de protection
des espaces informationnels
démocratiques
sur la base de système de réciprocité
tels que nous l'avons proposé
qui est défendu déjà par des états nous
devons trouver des moyens pour que les
gens étrangères puissent être traités
sur le fondement
d'un cadre juridique et pas sur des
décisions comme c'était le cas au début
de la guerre en Ukraine des décisions
sur la baisse de sanctions économique de
la part de la Commission européenne il
faut créer un cas juridique spécifique
pour traiter de cette question là pour
trouver une troisième voie entre la
refragmentation des espaces publics des
espaces numériques et le maintien d'une
ouverture
des démocraties tandis que les
dictatures elles sont fermées et mènent
des opérations de déstabilisation
voilà pour trois propositions c'est
l'occasion ce texte de mettre en place
un régime de responsabilité pour les
différents acteurs des droits et des
devoirs qui doivent sont pas les mêmes
pour les différents types d'acteurs et
puis enfin je rejoindrai aussi
différents intervenants sur le fait que
sans doute y a-t-il eu une
erreur enfin qui est un peu dommageable
au moment de l'établissement du DSA qui
est le rôle très important très très
important d'évoluer à la Commission
européenne elle-même là il s'agit bien
de dégager les décisions sur ces
questions de toute influence politique y
compris évidemment de la Commission
européenne elle-même merci
voilà merci c'est pas évident de parler
en dernier parce qu'évidemment
énormément de d'éléments ont déjà été
apportés je vais essayer de ne pas les
répéter mais de dire ce à quoi
éventuellement souscrit peut-être juste
avant de démarrer parce que je ne suis
pas sûr que l'Association des gens
listes européens soient peut-être connu
un petit peu dans son fonctionnement
parce qu'on a une effectivement une je
dirais une mission d'observation et on
recueille énormément de de
le vécu en fait des journalistes à
travers l'Europe donc là on passe
effectivement une dimension qui est
moins française et même si Christophe
Delor a rappelé un certain nombre
d'éléments au niveau européen et donc la
Jie et l'Association des gens historiens
c'est la section française de
l'association
La ej nous on compte 43 membres en
France mais la ej compte une vingtaine
de sections et plus d'un millier de
journalistes elle a été créée en 62 dans
les six pays de la CEE de l'époque elle
défendez par six journalistes qui
étaient convaincus la nécessité d'une
intégration européenne de manière
démocratique et qui croyait au potentiel
donc du journalisme pour promouvoir
l'harmonie européenne et c'est pour ça
qu'ils sont ils défendent la liberté de
l'information et avec les au-delà des
sections comme vous l'avez rappelé tout
à l'heure il y a une représentation donc
de l'IJ donc auprès du Conseil de
l'Europe et également auprès des
institutions européennes c'est
d'ailleurs le un autre vice-président de
la Jie présent à Bruxelles qui qui
travaille en ce moment
on a organisé une grande conférence en
décembre 2019 sur la liberté des médias
en Europe avec la RSF notamment et en
partenariat avec l'UNESCO et l'ambassade
de Suède à l'Unesco aussi je dis ça
c'est parce qu'on observait déjà à ce
moment-là une très forte dégradation de
la situation et des conditions de
travail des journalistes à peu près
partout en Europe y compris sauf
peut-être dans des pays
nordique voilà la Norvège étant le
premier pays où je crois que la liberté
de la presse et la demeure à peu près
intouchés au jour d'aujourd'hui mais
sinon ça se dégrade dans pas mal de pays
la France y compris et donc je pense
qu'il n'a jamais été aussi difficile en
Europe d'exercer le métier de
journaliste je tiens à le redire parce
que ça n'est pas uniquement
effectivement même si on l'a rappelé des
questions de concentration des questions
de évidemment de de qui possèdent les
médias et de collusion dans un certain
nombre de pays entre les pouvoirs
publics à certains nombre de médias
audiovisuel public mais pas que et
une difficulté je pense à informer de
façon totalement indépendante je
rappelle aussi que ce qui guette aussi
beaucoup les gens lisses c'est
l'autocensure et l'autocensure elle
vient pas de nulle part et je pense que
la question démocratique qui se pose au
sein de chaque pays
influe énormément
et d'empêcher les médias d'exister c'est
évidemment de les fermer on a des
exemples en date que je vais pas citer
je pense que j'ai pas le temps mais
j'avais envie ceci dit d'en parler de me
dire indépendants qui sont considérés
comme des agents étrangers et des agents
de l'extérieur qui empêcheraient en
urbanne en fait de mener sa politique
de façon souveraine donc
la façon de de museler la presse
l'indépendance de l'information elle est
protéiforme il y a pas une seule façon
de faire il y en a plein c'est pas
forcément de mettre les journalistes en
prison ou les assassiner même si ça on a
eu encore des assassinats très récents
dans des pays y compris aux Pays-Bas
donc il y a pas besoin d'aller très loin
en fait pour s'apercevoir que les pires
moyens existent partout mais il existe
une multitude de façon en fait
d'empêcher la pluralité de l'information
parce que c'est comme ça dont on parle
et je pense que
on est d'accord que les objectifs sont
louables je pense qu'il y a des bonnes
choses et là je peux pas
je ne peux pas m'exprimer au nom de la
uj parce que j'ai pas mandat à
représenter les vins sections
ni même au sein de la Jie même si on
suit ça de très très près et il y a des
je pense une reconnaissance avec ce
cette écriture de ce règlement d'une
situation de très grande fragilité de la
presse on sait pas très bien par quel
boule prendre d'ailleurs c'est très
touffu et c'est c'est parfois préfi
précis parfois je pense que ce règlement
a besoin d'un certain articles d'être
précisé effectivement comme vous l'aviez
nommé là tout à l'heure sur l'article 6a
entre la distinction entre directeur de
la rédaction et d'acteur en chef parce
que même si un directeur de la rédaction
protège ses journalistes évidemment s'il
est s'il est une marionnette ou une
semi-marionnette des actionnaires
ils ne protège qu'à moitié il est
lui-même pris dans des conflits
d'intérêts donc la situation de la
presse en fait elle est dégradée parce
que la plupart des rédactions n'ont plus
les moyens
de travailler ils sont sous staffés
comme on l'a dit tout à l'heure il y a
une difficulté en fait à
continuer d'exister pour un certain
nombre de médias indépendants ça n'a pas
été tellement soulevé mais au-delà des
questions de concentration de la presse
et de qui possèdent parmi les grands
groupes industriels les médias il y a
une question en fait de difficultés
économiques évidentes une baisse du
nombre de correspondants dans à peu près
tous les pays et à peu près dans toutes
les rédactions sauf à l'exception des
très grosses rédactions qui ont les
moyens de fonctionner et du coup la
le problème de la concentration c'est
aussi le problème de la de la de la
perte de tout un maillage de médias
indépendants on le voit en gris il
existe beaucoup de médias indépendants
en fait mais qui pour des raisons je
dirais
beaucoup plus dramatique dans ce pays
n'arrive plus à émettre parce que ils
sont fermés ils sont accusés ils ont pas
mis en prison mais simplement ils sont
dans la capacité de continuer à faire
leur travail et donc dans
dans la si vous voulez être dans la dans
la dans ce règlement qui est qui est
proposé ce qui peut paraître tout de
même intéressant c'est de de nommer en
fait ces conflits d'intérêts qu'on
retrouve dans chaque pays et quand on
parle de marché européen des médias je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec
Christophe de Loire que je sais pas si
on peut parler aujourd'hui de marcher
européen puisque le marché a tellement
changé avec l'importance la prééminence
des plateformes qu'on n'arrive pas à
réguler et qui finissent par devenir en
fait le
l'instance de de certaines régulations
infinie de des contenus de presse il y a
il y a la difficulté en effet de
soutenir et de renforcer le pluralisme
la pluralité et la diversité des médias
mais aussi l'indépendance des médias
parce que il existe des médias
indépendants un peu partout en Europe
qui sont plutôt en train de fermer la
porte
j'ai pas le temps de donner des exemples
et peut-être on y reviendra et ça c'est
assez dramatique pour la qualité de
l'information ensuite peut-être je
rentre pas dans les détails mais je suis
d'accord avec Cécile Dubois que
l'article 6b me paraît nous paraît tout
à fait intéressant
la question des plateformes est un point
de vigilance énorme je suis pas sûr
qu'il le règlement il réponde exactement
mais en tout cas c'est un c'est ce que
le fait dans débattre me paraît déjà
quelque chose qui est plutôt une avancée
je comprends la crainte qu'on peut avoir
au niveau des parlements
nationaux d'être dépourvu de en fait de
sa capacité à réguler le marché des
médias par contre on a en Europe une
énorme différence dans les cadres
législatifs alors si on a un cadre
législatif fort en France de par cette
loi notamment 1880 dans d'autres pays il
est extrêmement faible ma question c'est
un cadre légitime très faible en Hongrie
par exemple ou en Pologne euh est-ce que
ce règlement va régler si je puis dire
la question ça j'avoue que je je ne sais
pas je voudrais juste terminer après on
reviendra peut-être si on est encore un
peu de temps avec les questions sur le
le périmètre en fait de l'information
qu'il ne faut pas circonscrire
uniquement aux médias je pense au
lanceur d'alerte et évidemment mais je
pense aussi à toutes l'émergence de de
de victime de podcast ou de
d'informations relativement
approfondie qui ne sont pas forcément
uniquement produits par des médias
traditionnels je pense que c'est
l'information et la circulation d'une
information plurielle que que il faut
réfléchir le règlement n'y répond à mon
sens qu'à moitié mais le fait de le
nommer dans des battre me paraît très
important et en fait pour finir il n'y a
peut-être pas de marché nationaux non
plus des médias en tant que tel
uniquement puisque le l'importance de la
de l'information et de sa qualité de la
vérification pour la qualité de la
démocratie
fonctionne aussi de plus en plus en
regardant ce que font les voisins même
si on a réduit le nombre de
correspondants et même si
malheureusement des émissions sur
l'Europe notamment en France ont plutôt
tendance à diminuer qu'à augmenter et
donc le l'émergence d'un espace public
et civique européen puisque nous sommes
quand même au 100 au sein de l'Union
européenne me paraît important à
préserver et bon je le dis aussi parce
que je suis co-fondatrice de Vox Europe
et nous avons un peu cette vocation mais
de faire circuler l'information dans
plusieurs langues et de ne pas s'arrêter
uniquement aux frontières je pense que
comme beaucoup d'autres grands thèmes
importants l'information ne s'arrête pas
non plus totalement frontières donc
réfléchir à avoir un instance auquel on
pourrait faire appel me paraît
intéressant mais il faut pas créer une
usine à gaz voilà merci
sur je voudrais avoir quelques
éclaircissements enfin un
éclaircissement sur tout sur un des
points enfin sur des mots que j'ai pu
entendre puisque on est tous attaché à
à la liberté les médias à la protection
des journalistes
moi je voudrais savoir entre les mots
entre la liberté et la régulation il y a
tout un espace à mon avis l'espace
éthique de la déontologie
pour prendre des mots de Monsieur etno
les droits et les devoirs et moi il y a
une confusion que j'entends toujours et
je trouve pas les choses étaient
éclairées c'est entre la différence
entre l'indépendance des médias et
l'indépendance des journalistes
et il y a une confusion permanente et on
se demande si c'est pas une façon de
fuir ces responsabilités en tout cas
j'ai pas été plus éclairé parce que
chaque fois qu'on s'interroge sur
l'indépendance des uns finalement la
réponse se fait dans le domaine quand on
parle de l'indépendance des journalistes
et on nous répond sur l'indépendance des
médias et inversement et je est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est le texte et nous
éclaire davantage je suis peut-être
prendre toutes les questions et puis
vous répondrez chacun sur les points que
sur lesquels vous souhaitez intervenir
André gatelin
oui merci je voulais rebondir sur ce que
vient de dire
Catherine André que je partage
totalement pour avoir fait dans cette
commission en rapport il y a deux ans et
demi sur l'état de droit en Pologne
avoir rencontré beaucoup de responsables
de presse indépendante moi je crois la
question sincèrement qui fait que je
motive notre avis motivé c'est que les
instruments qui sont mis en place c'est
l'objectif de la Commission ne
permettent pas de lutter
efficacement contre le problème de la
liberté de la presse en Pologne je
m'entends d'ailleurs la Commission dans
le texte parle de l'attribution de
publicité d'État
l'attribution de publicités privées
aujourd'hui en Pologne il y a alors
l'oligarchie est un une vraie
explication le lien politique
extrêmement fort il y a deux centrales
d'achat d'espace qui sont complètement
aux mains d'amis le dirigeant du pouvoir
et qui décide qui ont droit de vie et
demeure mais c'est du privé alors la
commission là est dans la liberté
d'entreprendre selon ses principes et
ses bases juridiques mon problème c'est
la manière dont la commission qui
cherche et c'est une bonne chose et
l'Union européenne à s'emparer des
questions d'État de droit qu'elle a
totalement négligé dans sa construction
historique le fait sur des bases et des
approches qui biaisent la capacité à
réfléchir de manière plus globale à
l'État de droit et à ses fonctionnements
c'est pour ça que la référence au
Conseil de l'Europe c'est pas simplement
parce que j'y suis impliqué comme
d'autres parlementaires ce travail de
réflexion sur l'état droit la démocratie
et peut-être plus fort et mérite et le
cas de clubs radio il faut savoir que
c'est sa suspension est liée à deux
retards dans les délais de dépôt de
chansons de quotas de chansons
hongroise sur la radio
de de délai fait que la plus grosse
radio qui avait par ailleurs une
information indépendante c'est vu
complètement radié donc je crois que il
y a à creuser bien sûr il faut une
régulation mais je pense que
la question que vous avez soulevé des
définitions préalables des idées des
concepts alors on peut le faire de
manière quantitative en comptant les
mots comme comme ça a été fait c'est
important mais
on a un souci préalable un texte ne peut
pas tomber brut il doit donner des
justifications il doit clarifier les
objets et c'est là où je crois il y a un
rôle pour le Sénat mais aussi pour vous
à travers les différentes instances que
vous représentez du métier d'aider ou en
tous les cas de préciser ce qu'on entend
par indépendance des médias indépendants
du journalisme qualité du travail ou non
etc donc c'était plus un commentaire
pour dire qu'on est et puis sur la
question peut-être des directeurs de la
publication on oublie un est un double
support il y a un support de contenu et
d'information journalistique puis il y a
des contenus publicitaires qui en est
responsable un rédacteur en chef n'est
pas responsable du message publicitaire
qui alimente financièrement donc cette
question là à mon avis est pas simple à
poser parce que ça peut conduire le
directeur de la publication avoir
mais comme il a une responsabilité
finalement juridique avoir une forme
d'autorégulation par rapport à l'entrée
de moyens financiers
souhaitait poser une question oui merci
merci monsieur le Président merci
beaucoup pour la clarté et surtout la
liberté de de vos propos on entend bien
et je partage complètement le souci que
on doit aujourd'hui venir en aide aux
journalistes dans les pays où leurs
droits sont menacés mais comme il a été
dit aussi par ailleurs il ne faudrait
pas pour cela que ça
abaisse le niveau de protection dont on
dont on profite en France vous l'avez
dit très justement la loi de 1880 c'est
une loi de la liberté d'expression ce
qui est fondamental et moi je la relie à
la loi de 1901 sur la liberté
d'associations et 905 sur la liberté de
culte là on a
la base le socle de l'État de droit
républicain français Les Trois
Glorieuses et je n'imagine pas que pour
combattre une certaine forme
d'illibéralisme à l'est de l'Europe on
puisse abaisser ces libertés donc est-ce
que vous aujourd'hui vous voyez une voie
de compromis qui permettrait d'une part
de garantir ce qui existe en France et
qui a montré quand même ça ce sont bon
fonctionnement parce que quand une une
loi doit date pardon de 1880 on peut
considérer qu'elle quand même rempli son
rôle pareil pour le 1905 et 1901 donc
comment les préserver tout en permettant
en effet de de conforter
la liberté des journalistes dans les
pays où ils sont où elle est menacé donc
on a besoin aussi de de votre diagnostic
sur cette fois moyenne que nous
pourrions défendre dans notre résolution
c'est-à-dire de ne pas attaquer
de façon un peu violente le règlement en
considérant qu'il est important mais
aussi faire comprendre à la commission
qu'on peut trouver une voie médiane pour
pour faire que les les deux choses
soient conciliables voilà c'était sans
doute une question compliquée mais je
pense qu'on doit se retrouver sur ce
terrain là pour avancer ensemble merci
je ne sais pas comment vous voulez sur
quel point vous voulez réagir ou
répondre et qui commence surtout
monsieur Decker
alors je voulais revenir sur
l'indépendance
l'indépendant on ne cesse de parler de
la dépendance sans jamais la définir
est-ce que c'est l'indépendance du média
est-ce que c'est l'indépendance de la
rédaction est-ce que c'est
l'indépendance du journalisme est-ce que
c'est la liberté du média la liberté de
la rédaction la liberté du journaliste
je vais vous citer Hubert bovemérique
qui était qui est le pape français de
tous les journalistes et des déontologie
journalistique
qui disait un moment quand à la liberté
de chacun dans l'entreprise on sait très
bien quand on entre dans un journal
quelle est la ligne générale de celui-ci
donc en principe on s'agrège à une
équipe dans laquelle on pense pouvoir
jouer un rôle sans trop avoir à en
souffrir et donc ce que je crains le
personnellement maintenant c'est que
chaque journaliste estime qu'il a le
droit d'étaler ses tripes sur la table
de penser et d'écrire ce qu'il veut en
fonction de ses sentiments ce n'est tout
même pas aussi simple donc
je reviens à mon à ma triangulation
parce que je trouve que c'est
fondamental et que on y attache pas
assez d'importance
l'entreprise la rédaction et le public
c'est sans arrêt un jeu
l'entreprise recrute des journalistes
pour
fournir de l'information à un public
déterminé on sait très bien que on va
fournir de telles informations à un
journaliste un journée du Figaro et
l'entreprise Figaro va fournir des
informations différentes de l'entreprise
et de la rédaction et l'humanité et que
l'on parle pas de la même façon du pape
à Charlie Hebdo ou à la croix ça ne me
paraît pas posé un problème et on voit
bien que c'est parce que le public n'est
pas le même que les rédacteurs ne sont
pas les mêmes et que l'entreprise n'est
pas la même mais que c'est ce vous voyez
c'est ce lien alors effectivement il
faut de l'indépendance mais il faudrait
la définir c'est indépendance et je
trouve encore une fois que on insiste
trop sur le côté capitalistique de
l'indépendance alors que ce n'est pas de
cela dont il s'agit ce dont il s'agit
c'est véritablement que
la ligne éditoriale elle est elle est
fabriquée de façon plus ou moins
conflictuelle entre la rédaction et
l'entreprise en tenant compte du public
qui va recevoir c'est le choix éditorial
effectivement le choix rédactionnel il
appartient à la rédaction il appartient
sous la direction d'un directeur de la
rédaction mais il a aussi il est dirigé
vers un public quand on parle de la
neige pendant une demi-heure sur TF1 et
pas de l'Ukraine c'est parce qu'on pense
que le public est plus intéressé par la
neige que par l'Ukraine
on peut le regretter mais c'est ainsi
donc vous voyez bien qu'il y a un
rapport et c'est pour ça que on voit pas
alors je me suis peut-être mal fait
comprendre moi je crois qu'effectivement
il faut une MFA
mais il faut vraiment la revoir de fond
en comble enfin pour toute une série de
raisons que j'ai essayé de vous
expliquer je crois que c'est très
important qu'on est enfin un freelomate
en France en Europe tout à fait c'est
très important et je suis tout à fait
favorable simplement il faut il faut
revoir beaucoup de passage le dernier
point entre directives et règlement
l'avantage du règlement c'est que on
oblige pas les lois nationales à être
adaptés une directive soit obligé de
transcrire dans la dans la dans la et ça
prend des années des années etc etc
un règlement c'est d'applications
immédiate mais on n'a pas besoin de
transcrire forcément dans la loi donc
c'est quand même beaucoup plus pratique
à ce niveau là voilà excusez-moi j'étais
un peu long
qui veut prolonger c'est du bois très
vite
oui juste pour répondre aux questions je
pense qu'il faut vraiment pas jeter le
bébé avec l'eau du bain et que ce
règlement il a vraiment des choses
intéressantes je reviens pas sur les
lignes rouges sur lesquelles je pense
qu'on est vraiment d'accord savoir le 6b
pas de d'indépendance d'un journaliste
indépendamment de la ligne éditoriale je
pense que ce règlement est vraiment de
nature à répondre vous avez parlé de la
Pologne et de l'encadrement justement de
la publicité publique voilà justement je
il me semble que la manière dont le dont
le texte est rédigé en imposant
justement une allocation des dépenses
proportionnelle des objectifs
proportionnés non mais discriminatoires
etc
pourrait permettre un comité à ce super
comité à condition d'une gouvernance
élargie et je pense qu'il y a vraiment
un consensus pense que cette gouvernance
soit élargie aux éditeurs au concept du
21 théologie etc que ce comité pourrait
questionner un pays qui à loue tout son
argent assez à des régies il y a des
centrales d'achat verrouillées en disant
ok c'est des centrales d'achats privés
mais elles sont complètement
verrouillées et de ce fait on ne répond
pas aux objectifs de non discriminations
etc donc peut-être quand même il me
semble que les les différentes les
différents articles de ces règlements
permettent de tracer un chemin pour pour
peut-être améliorer un peu la situation
sur le marché privé et il parle de la
publicité publique d'État c'est-à-dire
ce que l'État investit dans les médias
c'est très secondaire
oui non mais c'est la publicité publique
c'est ce qui est très important aussi
dans le fonctionnement financier des
médias et j'imagine en Pologne aussi et
donc les régies qui sont en fait
indirectement enfin qui sont verrouillés
par l'État et qui sont pas vraiment qui
sont pas vraiment libres enfin il y aura
le règlement avec avec ce comité peut
quand même travailler sur ces sujets
évidemment c'est un parfait évidemment
ça peut pas être enfin évidemment c'est
un parfum mais c'est quand même des
pistes et notamment cet article la
Pologne et des autres pays sur
l'encadrement de la publicité publique
et intéressante il y a d'autres il y a
un certain d'autres articles je vais je
vais pas en faire l'énumération on n'a
pas le temps mais notamment aussi sur la
la rationalisation dans les mesures
d'audience il y a des il y a des points
qui ont été qui sont vraiment
intéressants aussi dans cet article et
qui permettrait sans doute d'améliorer
aussi les pratiques dans pas mal de pays
donc il y a quand même il y a un travail
vraiment d'amélioration dans dans
l'encadrement
des médias qui me semblent intéressants
juste un tout petit point par rapport à
indépendance média journaliste alors
nous on a une par exemple une définition
très claire enfin à notre sens au sein
de notre syndicat de d'un média
indépendant c'est un média dont la
vraiment l'entreprise l'éditeur
concentre son activité principale c'est
de faire de la presse c'est donc
il est édité
indépendamment par exemple il ne dépend
pas d'un grand groupe après chacun peut
avoir sa définition d'un média
indépendant mais enfin l'idée globale du
média indépendant c'est qu'il n'est pas
il est il est il n'est pas dépendant
financièrement à 100% de la même chose
il équilibre ça dépend dans son va dire
parce que l'indépendance totale on est
en équilibre entre les dépendances et la
différence entre un journaliste
indépendant ça veut dire que il n'est un
journaliste indépendant
s'il n'est pas attaché une rédaction par
exemple à partir du moment où il est
attaché à une rédaction il est
indépendant dans son travail mais à
partir du moment où c'est publié la
publication elle est quand même visée
par l'édition par le directeur de la
publication pour toutes les raisons qui
ont été évoquées donc il y a quand même
vraiment une distinction entre les deux
ce qui n'empêche pas qu'on peut vouloir
l'indé exercer son métier de journaliste
de manière indépendante c'est pas la
même chose que être indépendant
vis-à-vis de sa publication en fait
c'est enfin c'est entre la pratique et
puis le je sais pas si si ça vous
convient ou pas
monsieur Deloire non je vais m'attacher
à apporter une réponse à cette question
une question historique le fondateur de
l'un moderne les rougandit posé la
question sur la liberté de la presse
est-ce que c'est la liberté des
propriétaires de faire ce qu'ils veulent
de leur argent la liberté du journaliste
de dire ce qui leur passe par la tête ou
la liberté du public
à la fin tout c'est une question de
droit des citoyens
effectivement il y a une le mot terme
indépendant et utilisé dans tous les
sens s'agissant des journalistes
s'agissant des médias l'enjeu c'est
l'indépendance de l'information
c'est qu'une information peut pas être
réputée fiable si elle est sous tutelle
sous ordre
si elle dépend d'intérêt
qu'il soit
politique ou privé évidemment il peut y
avoir des lignes éditoriales il faut des
lignes éditoriales défaire citées
diversifiées on peut aller
la libre poursuite de la réalité
objective selon les statuts de l'UNESCO
je ne fais que paraphraser quel que soit
la contestation qu'on puisse être cette
phrase
peut amener à chercher des vérités
factuelles et à trouver des vérifier
factuelles très différentes en fonction
de ce qu'on cherche mais
il y a la nécessité d'imposer des
obligations méthodologiques le respect
de principe éthique et que le conflit
d'intérêt ne fait pas partie des
principes éthiques et donc il faut
trouver le moyen que la production de
l'information
qui peut être soumise évidemment à des
visions du monde ça on va pas détacher
qui que ce soit de vision du monde mais
soit détaché d'intérêt qu'il s'agisse
des intérêts
individuels des journalistes
évidemment je risque peut être corrompu
et il est de la responsabilité de
l'éditeur de virer le journaliste
corrompus dans ce cas là
un éditeur peut lui-même
imposer des intérêts de son du
propriétaire
et il est de notre devoir de s'y opposer
parce que dans ce cas là il y a une
atteinte au droit d'information des
citoyens qui peuvent être trompés et il
s'agit pas de journalistes digne de ce
nom mais
de porter des contenus qui servent à
défendre quelque chose et donc à la fin
des fins la seule indépendance
celle qui est centrale celle qui est
fondamentale c'est l'indépendance de
l'information toi je pense stricte sur
le point de Monsieur gatelin sur
effectivement le contrôle d'État et le
fait que il faut aussi intégrer les
contrôles indirects et compris avec des
parties qui peuvent paraître privé moi
ça ça me semble extrêmement pertinent et
troisième point pour répondre à la fois
messieurs ouzulia c'est égatolin
je pense qu'il faut pas simplement le
texte
il résoudra sans doute pas tous les
problèmes en Pologne Hongrie
mais ce qu'il faut simplement raisonner
sur est-ce que dans un cas on va réussir
à résoudre les questions en Pologne
Hongrie le cacher ailleurs et dans
l'autre on va affaiblir dans d'autres
démocraties
vu l'ampleur des enjeux contemporains
sur l'information
des plateformes numériques des effets de
la mondialisation non contrôlées de
l'information est-ce qu'il faut s'en
tenir là et pas utiliser ce texte je
pense qu'il faut sortir de cette espèce
de Dilemme ou de semblant de
contradiction pour aller plutôt vers
poser une vision qui peut être
totalement transpartisane parce que sur
ces questions là je pense qu'il y a
vraiment des visions transpartises à
trouver
des médias et des journalistes je
rejoins ce qu'indiqué Christophe de
Loire à l'instant ce qui est ce qui est
important c'est évidemment
l'indépendance de l'information c'est
pas l'indépendance des journalistes au
sens de corporation à l'intérieur de
l'entreprise évidemment ils sont au
service de la qualité de l'information
et de l'indépendance dans ce qui compte
c'est effectivement l'indépendance de
l'information et de veiller à ce que
l'exercice quotidien du travail du
journalisme ne soit pas perturbé ni par
des interventions extérieures des
pressions qui peuvent venir de bien
ailleurs que simplement des actionnaires
ni des interventions je dirais excessive
abusives de la part d'éventuellement
d'un éditeur ou d'un actionnaire donc
là-dessus on n'a pas de difficulté ce
qui compte c'est l'indépendance des
médias étant bien entendu que
par définition le pluralisme suppose des
visions du monde effectivement qui
peuvent être totalement différente et on
doit effectivement accepter que d'autres
médias qui ne partagent pas forcément
les valeurs qui sont les nôtres existent
aussi ce qui est pas facile au quotidien
donc sur l'indépendance des médias on
est tout à fait ok ce qui compte c'est
la qualité de l'info alors là-dessus
j'ajoute simplement une chose en réponse
à votre observation très juste sur le
rôle de double responsabilité du
directeur de publication le directeur de
publication il est à la fois je disais
tout à l'heure il est responsable de
l'intégralité du contenu du journal
c'est à dire que dans mon journal s'il y
a une publicité mensongère sans que je
puisse avoir deviné j'en suis
responsable si voilà intégralement
intégralement donc ça c'est aussi une
garantie le fait que il y a un directeur
de publication qui soit encore une fois
personnellement et pénalement
responsable
de l'intégralité du contenu du journal
ça l'oblige à trouver un équilibre
raisonnable c'est-à-dire que s'il
n'était par exemple responsable que de
la publicité et qu'il n'exerçait plus de
responsabilité effectivement sur la
rédaction évidemment le risque c'est
qu'il essaie de faire tout ce qui peut
parce qu'il considère qu'il
économiquement cette indispensable pour
favoriser le point de vue de la
publicité ou des conditions d'insertion
de publicité qui serait parfois limite
déontologiquement etc à partir du moment
où il est responsable de l'ensemble
c'est à dire à la fois de l'information
et de sa qualité et vis-à-vis du public
qui sont lecteur et de l'équilibre
économique de l'entreprise ça l'oblige à
trouver une solution et dans la pratique
c'est ce qui se passe donc cette
responsabilité complète du directeur de
publication quelque part elle est plutôt
au service de la qualité de
l'information que qu'un handicap sur la
situation en Hongrie je peux vous donner
un témoignage extrêmement direct on a
des au sein de lenpa donc l'association
des éditeurs européens des confrères
polonais et hongrois et très récemment
nos confrères polonais me disaient
écouter le règlement on a rien contre on
a absolument rien compte bon très bien
pourquoi pas maintenant on a aucune
illusion et si c'est pas un règlement
qui va empêcher le survenu de régime du
libéraux jamais et donc si on a par
exemple un représentant de la Pologne
demain dans le bord européen c'est
plutôt pire qu'aujourd'hui parce qu'on
sera supposé être présenté alors
qu'aujourd'hui on l'est pas et on nous
dira mais écoutez vous avez
représentants de la Pologne alors on
sait très bien que leur présentant de la
Pologne sera désigné par le gouvernement
polonais donc voilà très bien pourquoi
pas mais on n'a pas d'illusion c'est pas
ça qui va changer la situation ce qui a
changé la situation en Pologne il y a 18
mois c'est par exemple quand le
gouvernement polonais a voulu du jour au
lendemain imposer une taxe de 15% sur
toutes les ressources publicitaires de
la presse polonaise tout compris et
presse écrite digital télévision radio
etc l'ensemble des éditeurs polonais
c'est levé et mais écran noir page noir
pendant plusieurs jours jusqu'à faire
céder le gouvernement polonais qui a
renoncé à sa textation de 15%. voilà et
ça qui a conduit ça ce sont les éditeurs
polonais tous médias confondus donc le
vrai pouvoir effectivement là il est
économique il avait tenté d'étouffer la
liberté de la presse en Pologne et les
éditeurs et leurs journalistes bien
entendu l'ensemble de la profession
c'est levé contre voilà
dernière chose sur la votre question sur
le trouver un compromis possible
effectivement c'est toute la difficulté
c'est à dire comment faire en sorte que
la solidité du système français que nous
connaissons soit préservés et en même
temps essayer de trouver une solution
dans les pays où malheureusement elle
n'est pas et je reprends la formule de
Christophe de Loire qui dit il faut le
but c'est d'éviter la capture oligar
oligarchique et c'est ça qui est
compliqué on a du mal à le faire par un
règlement il faut sans doute explorer
des pistes pour éviter cette capture
oligarchique et là peut-être que
effectivement si l'Europe avait le
j'allais dire le courage politique de de
sanctionner des comportements qui se qui
seraient caractérisée par une capture
oligarchique ça pourrait être dissuasif
mais c'est vrai que c'est un problème
très compliqué voilà c'est c'est un
problème très compliqué
je voudrais rajouter juste un exemple
sur l'indépendance
de la formation chez je suis tout à fait
d'accord avec ce que Christian Delor a
dit juste pour illustrer un exemple qui
se produit relativement fréquemment
c'est d'avoir un actionnaire qui a des
entreprises ou des intérêts dans
d'autres secteurs et de ne pas pouvoir
publier une enquête sur ce secteur alors
ça se dit jamais vraiment comme ça mais
voilà j'ai une assez longue expérience
dans la presse et il m'est arrivé
d'observer le retrait et la modification
ou même simplement l'autocensure on ne
traite pas de questions d'armement on ne
traite pas de questions parce que ça va
poser potentiellement un conflit qui en
est vraiment un ou pas je dirais avéré
et que l'actionnaire intervienne ou pas
d'ailleurs voilà donc c'est c'est une
illustration
dernière question de Michel leger avant
de conclusion d'accord monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup
il me semble qu'on est revenu quelques
mois en arrière dans la commission
d'enquête et j'ai retrouvé bien sûr
l'été habituel que nous devons évoquer
tout au long de ces mois alors
j'étais très attentif à ce qu'a dit
Pierre auxoulias effectivement nous
avons en France est quand même un cadre
qui est complètement efficace même si
Madame André nous dit que il y a une
dégradation mais entre les gars jusqu'à
présent un cadre général efficace et il
faudrait bien sûr que on le conserve
c'est bien de réglementer légiférer
réguler mais encore faut-il que
on puisse avoir car même que les que
toutes les avancées nous avons eu en
France puissent résister et
permettez-moi de faire un parallèle
aussi avec les collectivités
territoriales vous savez on nous obliger
à être dans des intercommunalités ce qui
veut dire que effectivement on a perdu
certains pouvoirs dans certaines
compétences on a retrouvé dans d'autres
donc c'est vrai qu'il vous faut aussi
faire très attention
parce que il faut quand même que on tire
tout ça vers le haut et non pas qu'on
régule pour trouver un compromis moi je
souhaite qu'on tire vers le haut sur
l'indépendance des rédactions parce que
c'est ce qu'on a entendu pendant
plusieurs mois dans la
commission d'enquête on en revient quand
même à la base aujourd'hui et professeur
Evenot moi j'ai bien écouté votre
triptyque
je pense qu'à la fin ce qui compte c'est
le lecteur
un journal vous avez beau faire même si
vous voulez faire changer vous allez
perdre vos lecteurs ce qui est le plus
important je parlais avec un éditeur qui
a pris en responsabilité un journal un
peu plus populaire et qui m'a dit mais
je changerai pas la rédaction ni le
contenu éditorial parce que aujourd'hui
c'est notre lectorat donc je pense que
il y a des choses évidentes ensuite
on parle des médias on parle des grandes
entreprises mais aujourd'hui
avons-nous encore les moyens d'avoir un
média complètement autonome et qui soit
peut-être pas rentable mais au moins
équilibrée
en France je parle déjà alors à
l'étranger je connais je connais un peu
moins mais en tout cas quand on voit en
France
aujourd'hui ce que coûte l'édition d'un
média et quand même on est bien
accompagné dans les médias aujourd'hui
il y a les aides publiques qui
permettent de pouvoir faire les choses
on parle on oublie souvent aussi il a
distribution s'il y avait pas aussi de
l'aide publique de la distribution les
journaux ne seraient pas distribués donc
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui je vous pose cette
question vous qui êtes au cœur du du
sujet je parle pas des médias purement
numériques je parle aujourd'hui un
journal papier est-ce qu'on a encore la
possibilité en France d'avoir un journal
papier indépendant même si les
parenthèses qu'ils soient au moins
équilibrées sans les aides de l'État
sans rien est-ce que c'est possible ou
pas
pardon la réponse est clairement non
alors sur les aides publiques juste un
mot il faut quand même pas trop rêver en
pratique elle baisse chaque année bon
donc l'idée que la presse s'en sort
grâce aux aides publiques les totalement
fausses bien sûr elles sont nécessaires
elles sont surtout nécessaires parce
qu'elles facilitent l'investissement
mais c'est pas c'est pas les aides
publiques qui assurent l'équilibre le la
grande difficulté qu'on rencontre tous
non seulement en France mais partout en
Europe c'est qu'on est dans une
situation dans laquelle nos ressources
traditionnelles qui sont les ventes
auprès des lecteurs et la ressource
publicitaire baisse tendanciellement
elle baisse parce que les diffusions
payées baisse et que évidemment la
solution n'est pas d'augmenter le prix
du journal et elle baisse parce que sur
le marché publicitaire la pression
formidable des plateformes fait baisser
le coût pour 1000 de manière drastique
et donc aujourd'hui on a cette situation
vraisemblable qui est que la presse en
France n'a jamais eu autant de lecteurs
qui sont des lecteurs papier et des
lecteurs digitaux elle n'a jamais eu
autant de lecteurs l'audience de la
presse en France est à des niveaux
records record et pour autant elle a
jamais été autant en difficulté pourquoi
parce que la ressource vente baisse et
que la ressource publicitaire baisse
parce que le coût pour 1000 sur Internet
et ridicule par rapport au coût pour
mille papiers donc on a cette situation
où on a un effet ciseaux on a des
ressources traditionnelles qui baissent
et on est contraint d'investir
lourdement dans les mutations digitales
parce qu'on sait très bien que c'est
l'avenir et dont on sait que la
rentabilité de ces investissements que
nous faisons dans le digital ne viendra
que en 3 4 5 ans à condition que
effectivement la régulation des
plateformes existent parce
qu'aujourd'hui le grand défi c'est ça
est-ce qu'on va pouvoir gagner des
ressources de lecteurs
sur Internet et des ressources
publicitaires sur Internet alors qu'on a
une pression sur les prix considérables
qui nous oblige à faire des offres
d'abonnement digitaux à des prix très
très bas et avoir des ressources
publicitaires à des niveaux de coupe
pour 1000 très très bas et c'est pour ça
que nous sollicitons effectivement
une meilleure aide publique pendant au
moins quelques années trois quatre
années qui vont être les années
absolument clé pour qu'on soit capable
d'investir pour assurer l'avenir et la
transition digitale alors même que on a
des ressources classiques qui c'est ça
la difficulté
sur le sénateur vous avez posé deux
questions une question philosophique une
question économique la question
philosophique c'est est-ce que
finalement la fin c'est pas juste le
lecteur qui décide
ça c'est une vision selon laquelle
un récepteur de contenu peut de lui-même
distinguer ce qui est vrai faux et qu'à
la fin l'espace public n'a pas besoin
d'être organisé du tout chacun choisit
distingue
le vrai du faux
ça n'est pas la possession des
démocraties tout au long du 20e siècle
et de leur construction
un espace public comme celui-là était
l'espace public d'avant la Première
Guerre mondiale et les médias
qui pouvaient être sous l'influence de
dirigeants politiques ou d'oligarques de
journalistes qui n'étaient pas doté de
règles ont pu me mener au pire conflit
un espace public dérégulé c'est un
espace public ou règne purement peuvent
régner purement les passions les
emportements et les la désinformation et
les rumeurs c'est pour ça qu'en 1918 le
Syndicat national des journalistes a été
dicté une charte la charte de
déontologie des journalistes parce que
les médias avaient pu venir mener au
conflit c'est pour ça qu'après la pour
d'autres raisons mais enfin du même
acabit que
après la Seconde Guerre mondiale il y a
eu la construction et des garanties qui
ont été apportées et ça c'est vrai dans
l'ensemble des pays
c'est la dérégulation après les années
Reagan et peu à peu le démantèlement par
la Cour suprême d'un certain nombre de
garanties américaines qui a amené à la
création de médias polarisés d'abord Fox
News ensuite de l'autre côté et qui
amène à ce que
on a des espaces polarisés et qu'à la
fin les gens ne veulent plus vivre dans
le même pays donc est-ce qu'on pense la
question c'est est-ce qu'on pense qu'il
faut il y a des principes démocratiques
à imposer dans l'espace public pour
favoriser le pluralisme pour favoriser
la fiabilité où est-ce que c'est ça
vient swingerises
je ne crois pas que ça vienne de
soi-même et on a besoin sur
est-ce qu'aujourd'hui il y a des médias
pourraient vivre de même sans être
rachetés et on a connu des exemples de
journaux pourtant pas fortement
sympathique a priori du point de vue de
leur ligne éditoriale vis-à-vis des
milliardaires aller finalement vouloir
être racheté c'est vrai
et ça n'en finira pas
si précisément des mesures ne sont pas
prises pour que l'argent finance le
journalisme parce qu'aujourd'hui
l'argent est notamment l'argent de la
publicité ils financent d'abord les
plateformes numériques et des
plateformes américaines
deux qui ont capté les deux tiers du
marché publicitaire donc évidemment la
réponse à votre question est aujourd'hui
non
mais c'est précisément la responsabilité
des parlementaires que de trouver les
moyens que le journalisme de qualité
soit financé et ça c'est en mettant en
place des mécanismes de marché
très respectueux des principes
démocratiques du pluralisme n'orientant
pas le journalisme laissant la liberté
totale des lignées éditoriales mais que
de trouver des moyens parce que
captation publicitaire
captation des contenus demain captation
par l'intelligence artificielle où il
sera même impossible de capter l'origine
initiale des contenus on n'a pas fini de
dériver sauf si des mesures législatives
sont prises
donc on essaie de vous défendre
aujourd'hui le Sénat non vous savez que
depuis le 1er janvier les éditeurs
doivent payer une contribution à Citeo
ce qui n'est pas le cas jusqu'à présent
donc nous avons nous déposer un texte
pas plus tard que cette semaine mardi
soir voilà on a débattu et on a pris
notre décision qui a été prise à
l'Assemblée donc au Sénat vous avez
aussi des défenseurs de la presse
très bien oui allez-y monsieur
[Musique]
il me semble que il y aurait à creuser
une idée de financer véritablement
la liberté de l'information
la liberté de la presse des médias comme
on l'appelle moi j'appelle de mes vœux
une Fondation européenne pour la liberté
de
l'information
qui c'est pas la même chose que le
règlement ça serait vraiment une
possibilité d'injecter dans comme le
concert le consortium international des
journalistes comme etc qui se réunissent
pour faire des enquêtes communes et là
il y aurait véritablement quelque chose
à faire alors ça fait encore trois fois
que je le propose depuis 2009 donc je
vais me répéter encore mais un
observatoire du pluralisme et de la
transparence qui qui regrouperait toutes
les données européennes à tous les
niveaux et puis une fondation qui
appuyait sur ou qui a pu rester
l'observateur ou appuyer sur cette
observatoire pour financer tout ça parce
que le financement alors je réponds
aussi
à Monsieur logis en vitesse il y a
quelques il y a quelques journaux qui
sont rentables
il y en a quelques-uns
le groupe le monde est redevenu rentable
et chacun de ces journaux
est-ce qu'il était tout à fait
extraordinaire parce qu'ils sont
complètement mais le Monde diplomatique
qui appartient à Xavier Niel donc vous
voyez c'est vraiment la pression de
l'actionnaire sur la rédaction se voit
pas très bien
le monde Courrier International Télérama
et la ville et les cinq
journaux qui vont partie du groupe Le
Monde sont rentables donc pardon
oui les plus maintenant c'est terminé
maintenant ça s'est rééquilibré
bon bah oui bah si il faut lire les
comptes moi je dédie tous les ans
je tiens mais je tiens mon fichier excel
à jour
bon c'est mon job il y a il y en a
d'autres qui font autrement par exemple
le groupe Figaro est rentable non pas
parce que le journal est rentable le
journal perd de l'argent mais CCM
Benchmark et les voyages et autres
choses comme ça finance le
journal bon évidemment évidemment les
éditeurs depuis des dizaines d'années
depuis 1973 début de la crise de la
presse en France quand il a fallu fermer
Paris jour et puis ensuite quand le
combat devait être fermé et qu'on
pouvait pas laisser un journal de la
résistance le journal de Camus du défunt
Camus être fermé on a créé les aides les
premières aides à la presse en 73 ça
fait 50 ans depuis 50 ans les éditeurs
de presse vous demandent de l'argent
pour
non pas pour investir
mais pour pour boucler les fins de mois
il faut le dire bon
voilà c'est l'essentiel va quand même à
la distribution de la presse-papier dont
l'avenir est quand même assez compromis
à la résorption du plan imprime etc bon
que Jean-Michel Baillet a à vous
assoutirez avec quand même à vous au
gouvernement et à l'Assemblée nationale
beaucoup beaucoup d'argent
et il y en a plein d'autres comme ça et
on n'a pas encore fini d'indemniser le
départ des syndicats du livre parisien
quand tout a été regroupé chez ricobono
donc vous voyez bon mais voilà oui c'est
bon moi je
crois vraiment que il faudrait créer une
fondation pour la liberté de
l'information merci à part ça je voulais
juste vous dire encore une toute petite
chose
sur la vérité c'est le problème des fake
news
je vais vous citer
Marcel Proust c'est toujours un bon
auteur dans Du côté de chez Swann
l'effet ne pénètre pas dans le monde où
vivent nos croyances ils n'ont pas fait
naître celle-ci il ne les détruisent pas
ils peuvent le rafliger les plus
constants démentis sans les affaiblir et
donc la question des fake news ne sera
pas seulement réglé je crois beaucoup à
la déontologie pour régler une partie de
la question des fake news je crois
beaucoup à tout un tas de choses mais
c'est d'abord le fait que nous sommes
chacun enfermés dans notre bulle
informationnelle et que ça c'est très
difficile d'en sortir merci madame
Dubois pour deux minutes parce que je
voudrais que nos deux rapporteurs
puissent conclure et synthétiser
pour revenir sur le la liberté de la
presse et de l'information
juste une chose en France on a la loi de
il faut la préserver elle a déjà été
attaquée plusieurs fois ces dernières
années rogner sur plusieurs points donc
là on discute d'un règlement européen et
si on veut bien faire on peut aussi
commencer par s'assurer que la loi de 81
on ne continue pas à la détricoter mais
au contraire on la renforce et on a une
loi qui a été qui date d'il y a quelques
années sur le secret des affaires qui a
fait quand même pas mal de torts à la
presse régulièrement on a un certain
nombre d'éditeurs qui sont attaqués qui
finissent par gagner mais certains ont
dû aller jusque justement la Cour
européenne de justice donc remettons les
choses dans l'ordre dans la bonne
hiérarchie de la loi de 81 déjà ce
serait pas mal juste une toute petite
chose par rapport à l'économie
je vais pas je vais pas détailler toutes
les propositions que nous faisons pour
un financement pérenne de la presse de
l'information indépendante on a nous une
proposition qui peut-être va un peu dans
le sens de celle de votre guevenot on a
une proposition beaucoup plus large qui
à la fois concerne le financement mais
aussi
mais aussi toutes les problématiques
liées à l'information qui est de créer
un conseil national de la presse qui
serait à l'image du Conseil national de
la musique et de conseils nationaux qui
existent justement déjà en France qui
permettraient de construire un dialogue
permanent entre justement des
parlementaires entre les représentants
de l'État entre les éditeurs entre les
représentants de journalistes pour pour
à la fois pour travailler sur les
questions de financement pour travailler
sur les questions la question
essentielle qui nous préoccupent qui est
aujourd'hui puisque nous nous sommes pas
pour l'instant dans une démocratie
libérale la question essentielle c'est
quand même effectivement cette diff fake
news celle de l'océan d'informations et
de mélange dans lequel on ne se retrouve
pas et dans lequel les citoyens ont
beaucoup de mal à trouver de
l'information et toutes ces questions là
nous nous proposons de des travailler
vraiment dans un de construire un
conseil national de la presse voilà je
vous souhaitez conclure là dessus
merci on va conclure Michel
en quelques mots puis Catherine
je voulais vous dire que j'ai pas mal de
plaisir à assister ce matin
cette réunion et je vous remercie bien
sûr les deux présidents de nos de nos
commissions et puis bien sûr aussi tous
les intervenants mais j'ai l'habitude de
rencontrer
à l'occasion des travaux que nous
faisons sur l'état de la presse alors
juste quelques lignes de force qu'on
peut retenir parce que j'ai entendu tout
d'abord l'extrême difficulté d'appliquer
des règles quand on soit peu harmonisé
entre des pays de tradition différentes
on en a bien on a bien senti des choses
je garde en mémoire d'ailleurs et je
dois pas être le seul audition de Thomas
rabais
le président du groupe allemand
berthelsmann devant la commission
d'enquête il avait exposé la vision
allemande de la concentration et des
relations entre éditeurs et rédactions
qui étaient issue d'une culture
juridique et même politique tout à fait
autre que nous avons chez nous ensuite
dans la même lignée je relève
l'existence dans notre pays d'un corpus
juridique très ancré et relativité
souvent de la loi de 1895 et une
conception du pluralisme passionnant
construite depuis plus d'un siècle je ne
crois pas du tout que l'on puisse
toucher à cet édifice par le biais d'un
règlement européen dont la nécessité
pour nous mérite d'être pesé qui ne
serait pas débattus devant les
parlements nationaux
enfin je salue encore comme notre
président en introduction l'excellente
initiative qui consiste à associer nos
commissions donc aux travaux sur
l'Europe très Adamant il souhaite que
cette approche soit poursuivie qu'ils
soient informés aussi de l'avancée de ce
texte merci beaucoup
à quelques mots en complément pour
conclure cette table ronde comme mon
collègue Michel logé je me réjouis nous
nous réjouissons parce que je parle au
nom de mes deux autres collègues
co-rapporteurs nous ne régissons de
poursuivre ce travail avec nos collègues
de la commission de la culture parce que
comme l'on rappelait les deux présidents
il y a des travaux antérieurs qui
alimentent nécessairement par pas de
rien ici au Sénat qui alimente notre
réflexion et nous poursuivrons sur la
partie audiovisuel parce que vous
l'aurez remarqué ce matin nous avons
parlé que de la presse écrite et
finalement c'était pas plus mal parce
que ça nous a permis d'approfondir je
pense le sujet
avec vous nous poursuivrons nos travaux
et nous essaierons aussi de dialoguer
avec le rapporteur pour avide pour la
Commission du marché antérieur qui est
français puisque c'est Geoffroy Didier
donc pour nous ça sera important aussi
d'échanger alors moi j'étais très
sensible au cri du coeur de Christophe
de Loire qui nous a dit mais en paraît
vous du sujet on est en tournant il faut
que le Sénat soit offensif bon je crois
pouvoir dire que le Sénat a toujours été
assez offensif
si au nombre de sujets particulièrement
au niveau européen non seulement on a
été offensif n'est-ce pas Laurent mais
on a été dans l'anticipation bien
souvent sur bien des sujets je pense aux
droits voisins par exemple mais le prix
unique du livre numérique les droits
d'auteur bien donc nous continuons à
être dans cette état d'esprit ce n'est
pas parce que nous avons émis beaucoup
de réserves sur le texte notamment au
regard du principe de subsidiarité que
nous n'allons pas nous emparer du texte
au fond et que nous n'avons pas tenté au
contraire de l'améliorer le plus
possible notre souci est Cécile de
Dubois vous l'avez souligné c'est que
nous ne voulons pas écraser notre propre
législation notamment cette fameuse loi
de 1884 pour nous un phare et qui a fait
ses preuves et ce que nous avons
constaté c'est que selon les décembre
l'état de l'agitation n'est pas aussi
protectrice que cela et que il y a ce
risque d'homogénisation par le bas qui
nous fait assez peur et que nous
souhaitons absolument préserver nos
acquis ici
en France ça veut pas dire tout est
parfait en France mais il y a un certain
nombre
de comment dirais-je de points
essentiels qui et vous les avez
soulignés d'ailleurs à travers le temps
on permet de maintenir aussi ce principe
de liberté des médias les objectifs on
les partage tous nous sommes très
préoccupés de l'État de droit dans
certains pays européens
j'étais intéressé aussi par la typologie
et évoquée par Patrick Evenot qui nous
place nous autres aussi la France dans
un pays où les choses pourraient aussi
être menaçante donc on doit être
extrêmement vigilant et nos travaux
doivent permettre d'apporter des
solutions essentielles alors on a bien
pris en compte les remarques que vous
avez effectuées les uns et les autres
notamment sur l'article 6 sur l'article
[Musique]
A et 6b c'est vrai que c'était des
remarques différenciées
si ça notamment monsieur le Président
la question de la responsabilité des
directeurs et des rédacteurs
l'article 17 sur le rôle des plateformes
et ce que j'ai noté ce que nous avons
noté c'est que vous avez tous évoqué la
problématique des plateformes il y a
même quelqu'un c'est un lapsus assez
intéressant je crois que c'est vous
madame qui avait dit
pour moi c'était comment lapsus
si les plateformes peuvent être régulés
peuvent être régulés ça veut dire que
moi je dis pas qu'elles peuvent être
elles doivent être régulées doivent être
réglés en principe elles doivent être
régulées avec ce que nous avons voté le
le DS
mais en effet on l'avait constaté aussi
avec Laurence Patrice compta nous avons
été co-rapporteurs de la vie sur le DSA
nous pensons que le texte au regard de
la régulation des plateformes ne va pas
encore assez loin mais c'est toujours la
même chose au niveau européen il faut
trouver les consensus avec les autres
États membres et on peut pas toujours
faire valoir un certain nombre
d'exigences que que nous nous portons et
qui répondent aux d'ailleurs aux
interrogations que vous avez posé par
exemple le pouvoir donner excessive aux
plateformes de retirer des contenus au
détriment de la liberté d'expression au
détriment même de la presse sur ce sujet
nous avons été sensibles
à la proposition de Christophe de Loire
qui est d'inverser un peu
le raisonnement et d'exiger des
plateformes
construisent la fiabilité de
l'information en réalité plutôt que
d'être dans le retrait des contenus
construire créer les conditions de
l'exposition du journaliste
professionnel en de l'information
professionnelle donc ce sont des
éléments que bien sûr nous nous
prendrons en compte la question la
précarité des journalistes notamment de
a été évoqué et nous en sommes bien
conscients mais vous l'avez évoqué de
façon
très prégnante
c'est en effet ça fait partie également
en effet
du du sujet
et nous remercions parce qu'à travers
cette audition on a permis de connaître
en fait l'association que vous animez et
la dimension réellement européenne en
réalité du du journaliste voilà je vais
pas être tellement plus bavarde j'ai
pris beaucoup de notes comme mes
collègues simplement vous vous redire
que notre souci c'est une ambition bien
entendu mais dans le respect aussi de
nos acquis fondamentaux de l'État de
droit et notre législation qui pour
l'instant a aussi relativement fait ses
preuves mais bien entendu apporter notre
pierre à édifice nous tâcherons
peut-être aussi de rencontrer d'autres
parlementaires dans des pays aussi que
vous avez évoqué avec lesquels on
pourrait aussi pousser un certain nombre
d'idées peut-être deux trois idées mais
très simple mais qui mériterait vraiment
d'être défendu au plus haut niveau voilà
je pense que voilà merci au président
d'avoir organisé cette table ronde
merci
aux uns aux autres je crois que c'était
important cette table ronde c'était un
chemin que nous empruntons là
le chemin n'est pas terminé on a
simplement d'autres expressions
peut-être une TPE qui se pourrait être
utile entre nos deux commissions en tout
cas on était très à l'écoute de tout ce
que vous avez pu nous dire ce matin et
bien sûr le dialogue entre vous et nous
continuons
merci à vous
merci